안녕하십니까, 심탄 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리
모닝브리프입니다. 오늘은 7월 9일
목요일 1부 시작하겠습니다.
어, 한국 시장 어저께 굉장히 안
좋았는데요. 중국 시장도 동조화가
있었는지 우리 왕정부장님께
들어보겠습니다.
>> 네. 어제는 태그주화하면서 시수
맨너스 0.5%을 5%을 빠졌고요.
흥성태그 지수 플러스 5% 가이
급등했습니다. 정시 거대는 이정
6조의 수준을 유치했어요. 업종별
풀시면 어쨌든 유틸피션 부동창 업종인
컨셉고 방연도 산업제 소제 헬스케어
오픈 약세가 되었습니다. 위험 자세
회비 신리가 확산되면서 거에당 유틸
거 반량주들이 반등했습니다. 장강
전료는 + 1.5% 올라고 환능
수전은 + 2.6% 5% 전는 1%
가까이 올라왔어요. 어 구제 요가
제차 상승 등으로 에너지 관련주도
올라왔습니다. 배트로 최난 1.4%
중고 신화는 1.3% 올라왔어요.
이쁜기 거의 허실적 기대감이
있는데요. 그리고 광동시량 좀 어색
올라왔습니다.
>> 종자 우천는 염정 7% 올라고 신역은
염정 15% 청부 관동시는 염정이
5% 올라왔습니다. 동재 보는 어제
나오는 이야기는 대충 2분기 99억에
좀 나올 수 가능성이 있다고 그렇게
로머가 나오는데요. 그래서 주가는 좀
올라왔어요. 그래서 2번기 실정 좀
화면 좀 봐야 합니다. 충부 반도체
고생화 확대 그리고 4번기 AV 양산
등 기대금으로 1부 반도체 권중 올
우습니다. 한국기는 1중 8% 우하고
SMC는 5% 성민 반도체는 5%
정천테크는 4% 우라갔습니다.
저가 매수 자금 유입으로 소비제
권련주 어제도 올라하고요. 규정
모세는 0.88% 영양 영하주시
0.8% 올라왔어요. 어 7월 달
가정 수출 데이터 허조 등 기대으로
가정 관련주 원세 강세 보였습니다.
메디 클럽이 염증 4% 거래 가정
염증 4% 올라왔어요. 한편은
흥승테크 대형주들이 다 급등했습니다.
형튼는 3.8% 올라고요. 5일간
기준으로 하 하면은 그 11.4%
올랐습니다. 아리 빠바는 어제
12.2% 12% 극단했어요. 그
우정으로 15% 올라고 비하디어는
2.88 시험미는 거의 10% 가이
올라왔습니다. 최근에 일주일간는
17%도 올라왔어요. 어 반면 PCB
CC와 관련주들이 여정이 그냥 무진한
모습을 보였습니다. 승인테크는 마너스
3.5%
정는 마너스 2.4% 빠졌어요.
전기차 관련주도 거의 빠졌어요.
C티어룸 3% 빠졌습니다. 어제
신념물 구체 금리는데 염정 3b
하라했습니다. 연념물 구체 금리는
염정 1b 정도 하라하고 외야마
환율는 연못.15% 정도
잘라되었습니다. 감사합니다.
우연인지 모르겠는데 어 10센트는이
왕부장이 찍어 준 날 이후로 계속
오르는 거 같아요.
>> 아네 아쉬워요. [웃음]
아쉬웠어. 아, 말만 하고 액션을 못
하는 데.
>> 맞아요. 액션을 못 하고요.
>> 처음에도 계속 많이 얘기했는데 액션은
못 하고 어제는 반등하는 거 태별한
이슈가 없지만 약간 그 올래 틀어서
아 올래 아니고 작년부터는 계속
홍콩홍쇼하고 군의 시전을 롱하고 이거
롱쇼로 페어로 잡았어요.
>> 그래서 최근에 군내 시전은요
조정받으니까 아마 롱쇼 그 페어는
약간 좀 아
>> 그 수급 이유 때문에 올라왔습니다.
음. 네. 좀 전에 말씀 주실 때 어
상해 지수 또는 뭐 창업판이라고 볼
수도 있고요. 어 지수하고 항생 테크
지수하고 완전히 방향이 반대였는데 뭐
이렇게 될 경우에는 주로 홍콩에
상장된 플랫폼 기업들이 강세일 경우
이렇게 된다. 우리가 큰 틀에서선
그렇게 이해하면 되는 거죠?
>> 네. 맞습니다.
>> 네. 그리고 증시 거래대금은 제가
며칠 전에 이제 물어봤을 때
>> 네. 어 기준점을 저는 마음속으로 한
3조원 정도라 생각했거든요. 그래서
>> 3조원보다 많이 위면 거래량이 좀
많았다. 그 이하면 적었다 이렇게
앞으로 생각하려고 하는데
>> 네. 네.
>> 어 여기서의 증시 거래 대금은 상해
지수 기준이죠? 아니요. 통입니다.
전체로 전체 통입니다. 그러면 오히려
[콧방귀] 말씀드리기가 좀 편한데
>> 어 한국 시장은 지금 뭐 연일 어
주가가 굉장히 안 좋은데 어제 보니까
거래량은 굉장히 많은 거 같더라고요.
그래서 보통 주가가 뭐 바닥을
잡는다라는 것들 여러 가지 신호로 볼
수 있는데
>> 그중 하나가 저는 거래량이라고
생각하고 있거든요. 국 증시는 거래량
관점에서 봤을 때는 지금이 저가
매수다, 살만하다라는
관점에서의 아주 매기가 강하다.
이것까진 아닌 거 같아요.
>> 네. 지금은 성 그렇게 보고 있어요.
이정 요저의 수준 있잖아요. 약간
관망신이니까 되게 강하는 느낌입니다.
>> 3조 이상 하면은 그냥 괜찮습니다.
혹시 자 되면은 되게 그냥 예. 많이
하는 겁니다. 네.많
알겠습니다. 중국 시장은 한국보다는
뭐 낙폭이나 변동성이 상대적으로 적기
때문에
>> 한국 시장이 좀 다른데 전 어저께
한국 시장 보면서 제가 보는 종목들을
이렇게 클릭해 보니까 거래량이 상당히
많아서 전체 거래량은 보지
못했습니다만 아 이제는
>> 어 단기 바닥이라고 생각하고 사시는
분들도 많구나 그런 생각을 좀 해
봐서 여쭤봤습니다.
>> 네. 이슈 종목은 어 제 기억력이
틀리지 않았다면 처음 보는 종목인 거
같아요.
>> 아닙니다.
>> 틀렸군요.네
>> 인스퍼고요. 회사는 어 서버
기업입니다. 서버 만든 기업이고요.
서버 플란드 가지고 있는 회사고요.
시가는 25조만 좀 되고 포더 피아
센시입니다.
>> 아 서버를 보유한 회사
>> 예 서버 보유한 그데 그 서버
만들어서 파는 회사는
>> 야간 똑같아요. 될 아 네네. 어
글로벌 서버 시전은 2회 정도는
되고요. MS 10% 대열
1등입니다. 중국 서버 시전
1등이고요. 그리고 충구에서 AS
서버 시전은 1등입니다. 55%
차지하고 있습니다. 작년 매출
기준으로 하면 서버 매출 비중은
94% 되고 기사는 5.9%
중이고요. 어 어 끝제 어 끝제 전혀
때는 그 어 잠정 실적 나왔습니다.
3반기 순 있는 동의 225%부터
288% 증가 예상입니다. 역선호
하면은 2번기 수 있는 동의
494%부터
643% 급증하고 대충 승익는
20억부터 25억 정도 보고 있어요.
시장 출선단 예선치는 10억 위안
밖에 없어요. 그래서이 10억 위안
대비를 큰폭로 성했습니다. 그래서
어제 주관는 시자마자 바로 10%
성한 거 같습니다.
작년 말 기준으로 순위는 24억 정도
바에 없어요. 그래서 2분게는 거의
정령 하나에 번동 넘어갔어요. MP
마진 일정 자유 주는 방 없습니다.
어 중국 빈 빅비테크 빅테크 업체
회파 투자 화대로 서버 주문 급장에
달아서 허실적 허실적을 달했습니다.
1분기는 GP 마진 요정이 4%
나오고요. 동의는 3% 확대하고 서버
공급 증가에 따라서 2번기 GP
말수율은 추가적으로 개선 가능성이
있어요. 그 특히는 어제는 콘콜등이
있어요.이 회사는 언급하는 거는
4번기부터 충고 EHB 영상 따라서
실전 성형 가소가 가능성이 있습니다.
그래서이 부분을 기대할 수 있고요.
구형 청관사 리퍼 보면은 중국 고산
A의 투자 화대에 따라서 실전을
거승전 기대 매수 의견을
유치했습니다. 올래 부단 내년 내
훈년 매출는 각 동의 55.4% 4%
57% 42% 정도 증가하고 순위
있는 각 이전 대비는 어 뭐 102%
70% 60% 증가 추정되었어요.
역선호 하면은 원래 예상 PR는
20배 정도 되고 내년은 13배
내년은 12배 밖에 없어요. 타케로
내년은 20배 적용하면은 TP는
113을 위한 정도 가능성이 있어요.
어제 전가 대비 여전히 40% 이상은
없애 있습니다.
현재는 멀티플이 30배 정도
되는데네.
>> 어 예상 맨 마지막 줄에 예상
21배.
>> 네.
>> 어라고 하면
>> 아 죄송합니다. 예상 아 사계 PER
20배라고 하면
>> 현재보다도네
>> 어 열배나 낮은 멀티플을 적용하는데도
TP는 저 위에 있다.
>> 그럼 그 뜻은 이익이 급증한다.
>> 네.이 이 문제가 우리 그 포드어는
여기서 쓸 때는 그냥 원레인 그
건서스 기준을 했어요. 어제 실적
발표하인가 취식돼서 아직 반영하지
못했어요. 그래서 반영 다 되면은
이렇게 나올 수 있어요.
>> 실적이 어 강하게 다시 추정이 뭐라고
하죠? 예. 상향 조정되면서
>> 낮은 멀티플을 적용을 해도 TP는
113위원 현재보다는 저 위에 있을
거다.
>> 44% 업사이드를 말씀해 주시고
계시는데 요거는 우리 국년 증권
의견입니까? 아니에요.
>> 네. 아 그 TP는 우리 의견입니다.
>> 네. 군련청는 [목을 가다듬음]
그냥 TP는 제시하지 않았어요.
>> 광부장은이 정도 생각한다.
>> 맞습니다.이 업계는 평균적으로 보면은
대충 다 20의 피를 잡았어요.
>> 그리고이 회사 인스퍼는 그 자기는
다른 부품을 그냥 구매하고 졸립하고
파는 구조이잖아요. 그래서 수익률도
그렇게 높지 않아요. 1.5% 바에
없어요.이
>> 같은 비니스 모델 가지고 있는 회사는
공업이나 포스콘 그거 있잖아요.
포스권는 MP 마주는 3% 나오고
있어요. 그래서 대충이 호자도 3%는
또 나올 수 있다고 생각해요. 왜냐면
그 포스코는 엔비디아 집 구매하고
다시 조외에서 분하고 있고이 호자들은
중국 구산치 구매하고 중국 회자한테
받은 구조예요. [목을 가다듬음]
>> 그래서 중국 기업들이 해외치를
구매하지 못하니까이 효자 것만 쓸 수
있어요.
>> 이렇게 잘 봐야 됩니다.
>> 음. 그래서 이제 IT 불기 그래서
중국의 어 IT 생태계를 직접 이렇게
갖추려고 하는데 있어서
>> 네. 기술력도 있고 주목도 받고 그런
기업 중에 하나인 거 같아요. 네.
>> 예. 그런 기업이라면 우리 왕부장이
분명히 소개시켜 주셨을 텐데
>> 제가 기억을 못 하고 제가 한번
했습니다.
>> 네. 우리 밑에 보니까 어
밸류에이션이 장기간에 걸쳐서
리레이팅이 돼 온 거 같아요. 최근에
우리 왕부장 보여주는 기업들의요 밑에
PERPBR 차트를 보면
>> 어떤 [콧방귀] 밴드에 저 밑에서
이렇게 있어서 저가 매수 기회라고
생각되는 기업들 또는
>> 예, 1년 사이에 이렇게 막 하늘로
이렇게 취소승 기업들인데 여기는 보면
한 2, 3년 동안 계속해서 이렇게
>> 만한이 멀티플이 높아지는 거 보니까
>> 묻고 갈 만한 종목일 수도 있겠다.
그런 생각도 좀 해 봤습니다.
>> 네, 맞습니다.
>> 알겠습니다. 좋은 기업속했습니다.
감사합니다. 오늘 여기까지 들었고요.
어 미국 시장으로 넘어가 보겠습니다.
저희 지금 서영대리 아마 잘 지금
쉬고 계실 거고 그다음 유리프로 우리
창민으로 이렇게 넘어오고 있는데 아이
앞에이 여자분들 두 분 계실 때는
카메라 원근감을 해치고 제가 이렇게
막대한 거리의 뒤에 있습니다만 제가
훨씬 더 머리가 커버이게 나왔는데
상민 프로그램이 비슷해 보여요.
[웃음]
제가 실제로 보면 훨씬 크지만이
카메라의 원든근 감에 의해서 좀 작아
보이는 기쁩니다. 장민 프로 어저께
어땠습니까 좀 들어보겠습니다.
>> 네. 전일 미국 시장
말씀드리겠습니다. 전일 미국 시장은
미국과 이란이 공습을 주고받으면서
유가가 급등했고 지수별로 온도차가 좀
나타난 하루였습니다. 주요 지수 먼저
보시면 자우가 1.09% 하락하여
가장 부진했고요. SP 500은
0.3%
% 정도 하락한채 마감했습니다. 반면
나스닥은 0.2% 오르면서 상승
마감했고 무엇보다 필반 지수가
2.23% 반등해주면서 그제 급락분을
좀 일부 되돌렸다라고 볼 수
있겠습니다. 러셀은 0.8% 8%
정도 하락 보였습니다. 다음으로 우측
S&P 500 업종별 보시면 상승
마감한 섹터는 에너지 1.5%
상승하였고요. 정부 기술 1.4%
상승해서 두 섹터가 전부 아 두
섹터만 상승하였습니다. 나머지 섹터는
대부분 하락 마감했는데요. 소재가
2.5%로 가장 크게 밀렸고요.
금융이 1.9% 자유소비자와 부동산이
각각 1.6% 하락했습니다. 유가
급등은 연료비의 민감한 종목들에
영향을 줬는데요. 크루즈 카니발이
3.9%, 에어 BM가 3.9%,
델타항이 1.5% 하락했고요. 소비주
전반도 좀 약세인 모습 보였습니다.
반대로 에너지 단에서는 옥시덴탈이
3.7%, 이오지가 2.3%, 세븐이
1.1% 상승하였고요. 유가 급등의
수혜와 피해가 좀 섹터 단에서 갈려
갈린 그런 시장으로 보입니다.
다음으로 금리와 유가 보시면 10년물
국채 금리가 PP 넘게 오르면서
4.58% 나타났고요. 한 달 만에
좀 가장 높은 수준까지 왔습니다.
이년물도 4.21%로 같이 오르는
모습 보였고요. 유가는 WTI 기준
6.1% 급등해서 74.7달러고요.
7달러고요. 브랜트도 79달러선까지
올라왔습니다. 그 참고로 말씀드리자면
그 미국 전략 피중률 제고가 32만
배열 정도로 그 1983년 이후 최저
수준입니다.
>> 그래서 공급 충격에 대한 좀 완중
완충 장치가 얇아진 상태로 보여서
유가 민감도가 좀 크지 않나라고
생각했습니다.
>> 다음으로 왼쪽 빅테크 주요 종목
보시면
>> 아 여기서도 좀 온도차가 나타났는데
엔비디아가 3.7% 브로드컴이
4.8% 8% 오르면서 AI 하드웨어
쪽이 좀 강한 모습 보였고요. 반도체
단에서도 샌디스크 6.8% 8%
어플라이드 매트 2.9% 그리고
마이크론 1.1% TMC 1%로
전반적으로 반등하는 모습 보였습니다.
반면 메타가 2.0% 빠졌고요.
테슬라가 2.2% 하락 보였고
마이크로소프트와 구글이 각각 1.4%
하락하면서 좀 플랫폼 쪽이 약세인
모습 보였습니다. 최근까지 이어졌었던
하드웨어 그리고 하이퍼스켈러 구도가
어제 좀 다시 나타난 것으로
보입니다.
그러면 어제 장애의 핵심이었던 그
미국과 이러한 상황 현재까지
업데이트된 내용 말씀드리겠습니다.
어 화요일 호르무주 해협 상선 피격에
대한 보법으로 미중부 사령부가 이란의
방공과 드론 발사 시설 대로
공습했고요. 올 이란은 바레인과
코웨이트의 미군 관련 시설 85곳을
타격했다고 주장하였고 맞대응했습니다.
여기에 미재무부는 이란산 원유 판매
제재 면제 취소했고요. 트럼프
대통령은 나토 기자 회견에서 이란이
공격하면 열배로 대응한다고 강경하게
나가는 모습 보여줬습니다. 전쟁
제기는 아니며 이번 상황은 매우
빠르게 끝날 것이라고 확전에는 좀
선을 그은 모습 보었습니다.이
갈등의 성격을 좀 보시면 휴전 이후
이란이 공격한 상선는 모두 이란이
설정한 후르무주 경로를 따르지 않은
배들이었습니다.
>> 아 좀 경 무료 경로라서 수익과
무관한데도 공격한다는 건이 경로를
공식 경로로 굳이는 의도로 보이고요.
미국은 5만 쪽 경로의 항행 자유를
좀 지키는 모습 보이는 모습 말씀드릴
수 있겠습니다. 결국 전면전으로
제조화됐다기보다는 그 해협 경로
주도권을 둘러싼 좀 갈등으로
보입니다. 그래서 최종적으로는 좀
협상해서 정리될 수 있지 않나라고
저는 생각하고 있습니다. 다음으로
개별 종목 단원으로 내려가셔서 어제
4.8% 오른 브로드컴부터
보겠습니다. 애플이 미국 내 반도체
생산 확대를 위해 브로드컴과 300억
달러가 넘는 대규모 장기칩 제조
계약을 체결했고요. 애플이 지금까지
발표한 미국 제조 관련 투자속 중에
최대 규모입니다. 그리고 콜로라도
포트 콜린스에 있는 프로드콘 공장에서
15억 달러가 투입되고 시설이
확장돼서 150억 이상의 미국산 집이
생산될 예정이라고 예 말 기사에
나왔고요. 지난 6일에 두 회사가
ASIC 협력을 2031년까지
확대한다고 발표했었는데 이번에 금액과
설비 투자가 구체화되면서이 가시권에
들어왔다라고 말씀드릴 수 있겠습니다.
그래서이 부분이 좀 주가 상승
동력으로 작용했다로 보이고요.
다음으로 NB 관련 말씀드리겠습니다.
NBA는 중국 관련 보도에서 3.7%
상승하는 모습 보였고요. 아직 확정된
사안은 아닌데 보도에 따르면 중국
정부가 자국내 심각한 AI 부족을
해소하기 위해서 알리바, 바이트
바이트댄스, 디시크 등 주요 AI
기업들에게 NBI H200을 제한된
수량만 고매할 수 있도록 좀 허용할
계획이라고 합니다. 그래서 앞서
트럼프 행정부가 H200에게 중국
수출을 허관했는데도 중국 정부가 자국
반도체 산업 보호를 이후로 구매
승인을 미루왔었는데 이번에 고성치
확보가 점점 어려워지고 미국의 그
밀수 단속까지 강화되면서 입장을 일부
완화한 것으로 보입니다. 그래서이
점이 시장이 물량 자체보다 좀 막혀
있던 중국 판매가 실제로 제개될 수
있다는 시그널로 받아들였다고 저는
보여집니다.
다음으로 메타가 2.0% 하락하는
모습 보였는데요. 그 캐나다의 첫
데이터 센터를 짓는다고 발표했습니다.
약 100억 달러 정도 투자해서
1GW 규모 시설로 좀 작을
예정이고요. 주로 천년 가스 발전으로
가동되고 메타 자체 AI 모델과 기존
소셜 미디어 구동했을 예정이라고
발표했습니다. 그래서 캐나다에 짓는
첫 시설이라는 점에서 인프라 확장이
좀 넓혀지는 그런 뉴스로 보이고요.
네. 그 아마 아무래도 K팩스 투자가
늘어나는 뉴스다 보니까 주가는 좀
오히려 빠지는 모습 보였습니다.
그래서 오늘 내용 정리해서 말씀드리면
지정학은 유가 금리를 통해 좀 시장을
흔들고 있지만 좀 확전보다는 협상용
갈등이 이어지는 모습으로 보이고요.
그사 시장의 무게 중심은 집으로 좀
쏠려고 있었던 그런 모습으로
보입니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다.요 중간에 52조 신고가는
비어 있는데 여기
>> 어 5탄은 아닌 거 같고 없었나
봐요. 주신가가 없었습니다.
>> 어.
>> 네.
>> 언제 봤는지 기억이 안 나는데 이렇게
공나는 네. 어저께 다우가 계속해서
상대적으로 아홉프마다 다우도 1%
이상 하락하고 그리고 지금 저점에서
올라오고 있는 기업들이 대부분 SMP
500 나스닥에 있기 때문에 52주
신고가는 없었던 거 같습니다. 어,
국채 금리도 그렇고 유가도 그렇고
어떤 박스에서 계속 움직인다고 보면
역설적으로 금리도 그리고 유가도 지금
우리가 기대하는 어떤 밴드의 상단
어디쯤이 아닌가라고 생각하면
역설적으로 이때는 또 좀 사고
>> 지나치게
>> 아주 급하게 낮아지지 못할 거야라고
하면 밑에서는 좀 더 팔고 뭐 이제
이런 그 반대로 매매를 해야 하는
박스권 장세라고 보면 어 유가가 또는
금리가 지금보다 더 높아지기 어렵다고
생각되는 되는 그런 투자 심리가
어저께 좀 있지 않았을까라는 생각도
좀 해봤습니다. 오늘 아침에 뉴스
들으면서 출근하는데
>> 어 트럼프 대통령이 어이란 공습한
거는 그냥 단기 타격이다라고
부연 설명했다는 얘기를 어 들으면서
출근을 했는데 미국도 이게 확전이나
장기전으로 비춰지는 모습은 분명히
원하고 있지 않기 때문에 그런 또 그
매스컴 활용이 있지 않은가 하는
생각도 들어보면서 했습니다. 이부에서
미국 시장은 체일로 부사장과 좀 더
자세하게 보도록 하고요. 가상자산으로
넘어가 보겠습니다. 준혁님 가상자산은
그래도 저의 최근 느낌은 6만불
위해서 잘 견딘다. 그런 큰 틀에서의
생각을 갖고 있는데 궁금합니다.
어떻게 됐습니까?
>> 네. 24 가은 먼저 보시면요. 어
가정자산 시장 비트코인 시장이
62,000불 정도 위에서 계속
거래가 되고 있는 모습 확인하실 수가
있을 것 같습니다. 어이
62,000불 정도 수준이 중요하다
말씀드린 이유는 역사적으로 계속해서
200일선 어 200일선이 계속해서
아 죄송합니다. 200선이 계속해서
그 바닥으로 작용했었다라고 말씀을
드렸었는데 어 이렇게 단기적인 그
지정학적 이슈가 발생했음에도 불구하고
어 그 선을 잘 심리적인 선을 또는
기술적인 선을 잘 지켜줬다라는 거는
좀 굉장히 생각을 하고 있고요.
어쨌든 6만1불은 어제 그 정도는
갔다가 왔지만 결국에 지금 일봉이
마무리돼 가고 있는이 시기에 어
6,000불 위에를 지켜주고 오히려
그 200 주선 위회를 지켜 준다는
거는 굉장히 긍정적으로 볼 수 있을
것 같습니다. 제가 어제는 어
진정학적인 리스크 또는 트럼프가
이란을 공습하는게 어 이제 주식
시장이나 위험 자산 시장 선호에 어
조금 제한적으로 영향을 미칠 것
같다라고 말씀을 드렸었는데
>> 아니야 아니야 아니 하나도 영향 안
미친다 그래
>> 아 그렇죠
>> 제가 강하게 얘기했어네
>> 그 [웃음] 제한 얘기 아니라 아예
영향을 안 미친다고 말씀드렸었는데 어
어제 살짝 유가도 유가도 상승이
올라왔었고 그런 부분도 있었지만
비트코인 시장이나 어제 미국 증시
시장을 본다라고 하면 아까 대표님께서
말씀해 주신 오히려 국채 금리의
박스권을 예상하면서 역발상 매매를
하는 어 그런 흐름들이 이어지고
있다라고 똑같이 판단이 되고요. 예를
들어서 어제 같이 이렇게 공습을
하는게 전등이 확단의 여지로 어
이어졌다라고 하면 그 아이디어가
비트코인의 어 더 큰 급락이 나서야
된다라고 생각을 하고 있는데 그런
부분이 나오지 않았다는 점은 어 그
대표님 말씀해 역발성 매매 또는
비트코인 시장을 어 그 아니면 그
전쟁에 대해서 믿지 않는 흐름이
계속해서 이어지고 있지 않나 하는
생각을 하고 있습니다. 어, 전쟁에
관련해서 간단하게 한번 말씀드리면 될
거 같은데 어,이 전쟁을 지금 어,
지난주에는 희네이의 장례식이 열렸다.
그니까 이번 주까지 해서 희네이의
장례식이 열렸다라고 합니다. 그래서
희네이를 그 추인 추 어 그 길이는
그 추모 공간 어, 끝날 때까지는
공격을 하지 않았다가 공격을 다시
제기했다라는 의견들이 굉장히 많은 거
같은데 어제도 나토 회의가
있었거든요. 나토 회의 바로 직전에
어, 트럼프랑 아, 트럼프가 아니라
스페인과 모든 무역을 다 끊어라라고
트럼프가 발언하는 바가 있었습니다.
그래서 나토를 어 또는 나토의
동맹국인 그 유럽의 그 스페인을
굉장히 압박하려고 하는 그런 카드 중
하나 하나가 아니었을까 하는 생각도
개인적으로 하고 있고 그래서 결국엔
트럼프가 그 단 어 그 호르무시에서
있었던 그 미살 폭격 같은 것들을 어
정치적으로 그냥 또는 지정학적으로
활용하고자 하는 그런 폭격 정도가
아니었을까 하는 생각을 하고 있고
그런 것들이 시장에 좀 반영이 된게
아니었나 생각을 하고 있습니다. 어
비두 장기 차트 보시면 아까 말씀드린
것처럼 200주 이평선을 어 잘
지켜주고 있다. 어,이 부분이
공고무적이다라는 점을 참고하시면 될
거 같고요. 어, 비트코인 피행
그리드 인덱스 보시면 극단조 공포
구간에 어, 위치 있고 한 20 정도
기록하고 있습니다. 어, 미미하지만
긍정적인 부분은 비트코인 현물 ETF
순위 순유출이 최근에는 그래도
유입세로 지속이 되고 있다는 점은
긍정적입니다. 그래서 어, 21년
정도가 7월 7일 날 들어왔지만
어쨌든 유출세가 조금 멈췄다라는
점에서 시장이 어, 그래도 비트코인
가격에 경고하게 영향을 미쳐 주고
있는 것 같습니다. 어, 주의 실쪽
보시면요. 어제 이런 기사가 나와서
한번 가져와 봤습니다. USDT는
결제를 USDC는 디파일을 잡았다라고
하면서 스테이블 코인의 각자 도생의
길로 가게 됐다라고 하는 어 듀인프의
어 보도가 있었는데요. 어 듀는
온체인 분석 기간이다. 어제 말씀
주신 것처럼 온체인에 있는 그런
활동들을 어 잘 추적해서 어 분석
글로 내주는게 듀이라는 어 온라인
분석 기간이 하나가 있고요. 테더
테더의 USDT는 크립토 시장의
지배적인 결제용 스테이블 코인이 된
반면에 어 서클의 USDC는 디파이의
성장을 견인 중이다라고 합니다. 어
디파이라고 하는 거는 그 탈중앙화
거래 또는 뭐 스마트 컨트랙트라고
해서 아무도 아무런 중계인이 없는
상태에서 하는 거래 등을 어
디파이다라고 합니다. 어, 점유 1,
2등의 스테이블 코인들이 스테이 그
크립토 생태에 대해서 정면 승부를
버리기보다는 서로 다른 역할을
수행하면서 점차 다른 용 아, 점차
특정 어, 용처에 특화된 금융
상품으로 자리를 잡고 있다라고
합니다. 그래서 아까 말씀드린 것처럼
테더사의 USDT는 온체인 결제
부문에서 압도적인 우유를 점하고 있는
것으로 나타냈는데 어 2026년
상반기 동안에 USDT는 상거래
결제해 약 95빌년 정도가 정산이
됐고 어 2윈 USDC는 한 14빌년
정도가 됐다라고 하니까 규모 자체가
어 최소한네 다섯 배 정도는 나는 것
같습니다. 어 그 또한 USDT는
48빌리언 규모의 B2B 결제량의 어
한 92% 정도를 차지했다라고 하니까
어 결제 부분에서는 USDT가 굉장히
많이 쓰고 있는 것을 저희가 확인할
수 있을 것 같고요. 어, USDT의
최대 네트워크인 트론이라고 하는 그
어, 그 제 말씀드렸지만 뭐 그
지하철로 9호선, 7호선 이런 걸로
보시면 될 거 같은데 트롤이나
네트워크에서 토 토큰 공급량의
93%가 거래소고 아닌 일반 지갑에
보유가 되고 있어서 결제및 송금
자산에로서 역할을 잘한다라고 합니다.
이게 좀 중요한 포인트인데요.
거래소에 있다라고 하면 결국에
카지노에는 칩이랑 비슷하기 때문에
거래소 안에서의 활동으로 활용될
경우가 굉장히 큽니다. 근데 이제
일반 지갑에 보유되고 있다라는 거는
어 내가 뭐 결제를 하기 위해서 일반
지갑에서 다른 사람의 지갑으로
보내주는 활동을 하기 위해서 일반
지갑에 갖고 있는게 맞다라고
생각하시면 될 거 같거든요. 어 저희
돈을 어 어디 그 어디 뭐 온라인
캐시 같은데 충전하는게 아니라 개인
현물 지갑에 어 포함 그 보관에 놓고
있는 거랑 비슷하다고 생각하시면 될
것 같습니다. 반면에 USDC는
디파이 분야에서 지배적인 스테이블
코인으로 자리 매임을 하고 있고 어
베이스 네트워크 기반의 어 USC는
지난 6월에 한 2.6조 달러 어
이체 거래량을 처리하면서 모든 토큰
체인 조합 중에서 가장 높은 수치를
기록했고 어 이더리움 네트워크상에
USDC는 어 1.6조달러 정도를
처리했다라고 합니다. 어 베이스
기반의 USDC는 어 6월 6월 그
유통 공급량이 약 20배에 달하는 어
1일 유통 속도를 기록하면서 어
트레이딩과 디파이 그 디파이에서의
광범 활용성을 반영했다라고 하고요.
이런 분석 결과는 기존에 USDT와
USDC 누가 더 점유를 많이 먹을까
이런 경쟁 구도가 더 이상 유효하지
않다을 시사한다라고 합니다. 대신 각
스테이블 코인은 각 자신만의 영역을
개척하고 있으며 USDT는 어 결제
분야를 지배하고 어 USDC는 어
크립토 트레이딩과 디파이 활동 상당
부분을 뒷받침한다라고 이렇게 언급을
했습니다. 어 USDT의 공급량은
트론과 이더리움 사이에 동등하게
양분이 되어 있는데 어 USDC 같은
경우에는 새로운 블랙체인으로 막 황
그 확장을 하고 있음에도 불구하고
여전히 이더리움이 크게 집중되고
있다라는 점을 언급을 해줬다이 정도로
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서
마지막 문장과 그 첫 번째 왼쪽에
있는 사진과 가장 어 그 첫 번째
왼쪽에 있는 사진 설명하고
있는데요.이 파란색 부분과 주황색
부분은 USDT입니다. 그래서 어
아직도 그 USDT라는 어 스테이블
코인이 전체 스테이블 코인에서
차지하고 있는 비중이 한 60% 이상
된다를 어 확인하실 수가 있을 것
같고요. 회색 부분이 USDC입니다.
그래서 USDC가 어 오히려이
USDT의 점유를 막 뺏어 가는
거보다는 각각의 용처에서 스테이블
코인이 조금 커지고 있다라는 점을
설명해 주고자 했던 거 같고요.
오른쪽에 있는 사진 한번 보시면
돼요. 오른쪽에 있는 기사를 제가
하나 가져 왔는데요. 오픈라고 해서
제가 지난번에 한 180개
140개에서 180개 정도 기업이
특히 한국 기업들을 포함해서 어
기업들이 협의를 해서 컨소시엄을
만들고 어 지금 US 그 스티블코인
시장을 뺏기 위해 들어온다라고 말씀을
한번 드린 적이 있었는데 어이 후속
기사들이 굉장히 좀 충격적이었던 거
같습니다. 오 USD에 포함되 있던
기업들의 다수가 관련된 협의가
없었다라고 보도를 후속 보도를 했던
건데요. 어 그래서 지금이 180개
기업 중에 몇 개가 정말이 콘서
시험에 실제로 들어와 있는 것인가
하는 우구심이 커지고 있는 거
같고요. 어, 실제로 방금 말씀드린
것처럼이 USDT와 USDC가
시장에서 점유를 굉장히 많이 차지하고
있는데 이렇다고 하는 거는 원어와
달러 같이 자 이미 사용자들에게
친숙한 어 그런이 화폐로서 자리
자리를 10%든 60%든 이미 차지를
하고 있다는 것으로 저희가 반증을 할
수가 있는데 그런 부분들을 오픈
USD가 벌써부터 이렇게 컨소시엄이
약간 어 삐걱되고 있는 모습을 보면서
얼마나 점유를 뺏어올 수 있는가에
대한 의구심이 시작부터 조금 어
형성이 되었다.이 정도만 흐름 보시면
될 거 같습니다.
>> 음. 어,이 USBT라는게 실제로
사람들이 쓰냐라고 하는 걸 저희가
어, 체감하 체감하기는 굉장히 어려운
거 같습니다. 왜냐하면 어, 저희가
실제로 지금 쓰는 거는 카드로 굉장히
편리하게 핀테크가 너무 잘 돼 있기
때문에 카드로 결제를 다 하고
삼성페이, 애플페이 정말 많이
쓰는데요.이 아이쇼 스피드라는 굉장히
유명한 인플루언서가 하면 있는데요.
아이쇼 스피드가 나이지리아 국가를
여행할 때 어, 애플페이가 되냐라고
했을 때 안 된다라는 거절 답변을
들었습니다. 근데 너는 USDT
봤냐라고 했을 때 USDT를 허용해
줘서 USDT로 결제를 했었거든요.
굉장히 큰 금액이었는데 USDT라는
스테이블 코인을 통해서 결제라는
실사용 사례를 어이 유명한
인플루언서가 보여 주는게 어 이번
올해 초긴 했지만 있었습니다. 그래서
우리 같은 지금 어 금융 강국에서는
이런 것들이 실제 사용될 일은
없지만이 USDT 결제가 많이
된다라고 하는 거는 우리나라 제외하고
어 금융 여건이 좀 안 좋은
나라들에서선 실제로 있는 사례다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같고요.
어른쪽에 있는 걸 보시면 어 그
턴오버 레이트라고 해서 어 화폐가
얼마나 빨리 도느냐 이런 것들이 나온
수치인데요. 가장 위에 있는 어
그래프만 보시면 될 거 같은데 가장
위에 있 그래프가 USC입니다.이
베이스 체인 위에 베이스 레일 위에
올라가 있는 USBC인데 어이 턴오버
레이트가 많다라고 하는 거는 그
위에서 거래가 굉장히 많다라고도
확인할 수 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서
D파 부분에서 USDC가 굉장히
활발이 사용되고 있다는 것을 좀
뒷받침하기 위한 어 그런 차트다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다.
>> 저처럼 아직까지 가성화폐 시장에 좀
익숙치 않은 분들을 위해서 우리 주요
이슈 설명해 주신 것들 중에 맨 첫
줄 USDT, USDC가 무엇인지만
간단히 좀 듣고 넘어가 볼까요?
>> 네. USDT는 테더사, 그러니까
미국에 상장되 있는 서클이 하는게
USDC라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
>> 음. [목을 가다듬음] USDT는
홍콩 자본 쪽이 좀 섞여 있는
테더사가 있습니다. 그래서 USDC는
서클이 하는 거다.이 정도 보시면 될
거 같고 USDT는 어 홍콩 자본
아직 상장되 있지 않은 홍콩 자본
쪽이 하는 거다. 그래서 아무래도
USDC 서클 사과하는게 조금 더
투명하고 규제에 올라와 있는 어
스테이블코인이다라 보시면 될 거 같고
USDT는 홍콩의 자본이 섞여 있는
조금 그래도 비교적 불투명한 어
스테이블 코인이다라고 보시면 될 거
같은데이 USDC가 디파일을
잡았다라고 하는게 좀 깊게 들어가면
클리트 액트랑 조금 깊게 연간이
있습니다. 왜냐면 어 클레트 액트에서
지금 포함되려고 하는 것들이 디파이를
좀 더 활성화하고 그 SA에서 SAC
그리 CFT 손잡고 하려고 하는
것도이 디파이 활동 온체인에서 어
중계인이 없이 할 수 있는 거래들을
조금 활발하고 활발휘하고 규제를 좀
명확하게 해 주려고 하는게 클레트
액트잖아요.
>> 그런데 거기서 USDC가 좀 주도권을
잡고 있다라고 하는 점은 미국이
USDC를 조금 디파이 쪽으로 확
키우려고 하는 부분들을 저희가 어느
정도 확인할 수 있다는 것도 저거 어
좋은 포인트였던 거 같습니다.
어
많다고 하는 미국이 지금 클레트
액트를 활성화시켜서 디파일 그
명확하려고 규제 위에 올리려고 하는
거에 같은 흐름이다라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다.음
>> 감사합니다. 상대적으로 미국 기반의
어떤 플랫폼이 아니기 때문에
USDT는
>> 어 뭐랄까요? 그니까 디파이 쪽과
연결이 된다기보다는 결제 쪽으로 조금
더 집중을 한다. 이렇게 볼 수도
있을 것 같
>> 실제로 연결이 많이 되는데요. 만약에
이게 정말 규제가 어 미국의 유리한
쪽 그리고 규제가 규제 안에 들어와야
되는 쪽으로 가게 된다라고 하면 점차
USDC로 가게 되니까 USDT는
결쪽으로 자연스럽게 갈 수밖에 없는
거고 USDC는 점차 자연스럽게 규제
쪽에 올라와 있는 쪽으로 갈 수밖에
없습니다.
사람들이 돈을금을 거의 주고시피
하는데 저희가 현금을 모두 트래킹하진
않잖아요. 네. 그런 부분과 그냥
배를 같이 한다 보시면 될 것
같습니다. UST는 현금으로 쓰이고
USC는 어 온차인 온체인 그러니까
실제로 추적 가능한 돈으로 어 쓰이게
된다.이 정도 흐름으로 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 공부가 다 필요합니다.
저부터 조금 더 열심히 반복해서 좀
보겠습니다. 1부 여기까지 마치도록
하겠습니다. 잠시 위부에서는 좀 더
자세한 내용으로 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
함께 해주신 채울턴 여러분
감사드립니다.
>> [음악]
>> เฮ
[음악]
>> [음악]
>> 안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 예정을
체슬리 투자 전문과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 7월 9일 목요일
2부 순서 시작하도록 하겠습니다.
자 어제 미국 시장은 어 부분적으로
본조세를 보여긴 했지만 나스닥하고
필반 지수가 반등에 들어갔습니다.
좀 아쉬운 점은 10년물 국채 금리가
4.58로
그리고 유가가 6%부터 모습.
>> 예, 그렇습니다.
>> 예. 보인게 조금 아쉽고.
>> 예.
>> 하지만 중동 문제는
어, 항상 제자리로 돌아오기 때문에
>> 중동에서 전쟁이는
시장에 하락가면
항상 반등이 들어온다.
>> 예.
어제 조회수 실시간 조회수가 아니라
실시간 참여자가 2,명이 넘어가면
어 체슬리 인덱스에서
반등이 들어간다 했는데 어제
2,000원 넘겨지 못하고 어
80몇 명까지 봤었는데
>> 예
>> 안타깝게 우리 시장은 어제 또
패닉이 나오는 그런 모습들이 연출이
되긴 했었습니다. 막판에 외국인들은
보니까 전부 다 샀더라고. 외국 신.
>> 예. 그러면 개인이 간만에
팔았더라고요.
>> 그게 개인이 팔고 싶었어 판게 아니라
강제 반대입니다.
>> 예.
그런 모습이 좀 나왔기 때문에
자 어 미국 시장에서 전해지는 요런
노이저 때문에 투자 심리가 더
악화되면서
시장 우리나라 시장한테 영향을
줬었는데 그 간밤에 들려온 얘기가
메타가
캐나다 엘버타주에다가
데이터 센터
>> 예
>> 투자한다고
>> 그래서요 뉴스가
>> 아니 메타가 좀 유 컴퓨팅 자원을
지금 배열를 해야 되겠다. 뭐 이런
얘기로 나오면서 어 이제 투자 안
하는 거 아니야.
>> 뭐 약간 그런
>> 어 우려를 나타냈다면
어제 또 캐나다 첫 데이터 센터
투자는 어 또 이건 뭐지? 뭐 이런
생각이 들거든요.
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 어떤 내용인가?
>> 예. 그래서 어 이번 시장의 변동성의
그 시발점이 어 메타의 데이터 센터
돼요. 어 뭐 남는 뉴 컴퓨팅 자원을
제 3자에게 판매하겠다. 이거부터
시작이 됐는데 메타가 어제 그 한 뭐
행보를 보면은 어 전혀 그 AI
인프라 투자에 소극적일 이유는 없다.
요런 메시지를 준 거 같습니다.
말씀하신 대로 캐나다의 첫 데이터
센터를 어 10빌리언 달러를 들여서
어 투자하겠다고 발표한 건데
메타가 데이터 센터가 어 32개가
있었는데 이번에 이것까지 하면 33개
데이터 센터를 짓는 셈이 된다고
합니다. 어 엘버타주는 이제 캐나다에
있는
작은 엘버타주에 있는 어 스터전
카운티라고 하는데 동그라미
2,000원데 이제 점선으로 돼 있는
그 지역입니다. 아시다시피 이제
캐나다는 땅도 넓고 뭐 인구 밀도도
뭐 낮 낮은데 어 지금 카니 총리가
어 캐네다가 세계 최고의 아 데이터
센터 건설 국가가 되겠다 이런 것들을
슬로건으로 내세우면서 어 당선이
됐다고 하고 어 굉장히 그 데이터
센터 유치에 적극적인 데다가 어
메타의 어 이런 인프라 투자 니자하고
맞아 떨어진게 아닌가 싶습니다. 전력
용량은 뭐 1GW 정도 되는데 75만
가구의 사용량에 상당하는 전력
용량이라고 보시면 될 거 같고 전력은
대부분 어 1천원 가스 화력 발전으로
한다고 하고요. 그리고 멘타가 신규
발전 설비 자금을 직접 부담하면서
엘보타 전력망에 연결할 예정이라고
합니다.
고용 효과는 건설 인력이 한 3,명
정도 들어가고요. 완공 후에 정규지가
한 300명 정도 일하게 될 거라고
하고 용도는 자사 AI 모델 및 소셜
미디어 앱인 인스타그램하고 페이스북
같은 거를 고동하기 위한 것이고
별도의 잉여 컴퓨팅 용량을 외부
기업에 판매하는 클라우드 사업서 사업
진출도 검수 중이라고 합니다.
그래서이 부분이 되게 어 중요한데 어
메타가 어 본격적으로 클라우드 사업에
진출하려고 하나라는 얘기들이 계속
나오고 있는데 어 그렇게 되면은 기존
사업자인 마이크로소프트나 아마존이나
아 구글 어 이런 회사들도 좀
긴장하게 될 거 같습니다. 그 메타의
그 CEO인 마크 주코버그 같은
경우에 이제 굉장히 공격적 어 성향을
가지고 있는데 이번에 실적 발표 때
어 실적하고 어 관련된 그 AI
케펙스 코멘트가 나올 텐데 그
코멘트가 어떻게 나올지 진짜 어이
전반적인 어 클라우드 사업자뿐만
아니라 AI 인프라 쪽에 추세 자체를
더 강화시키는 역할을 할지
아니면 반대로 갈지요 부분이 좀
굉장히 기추가 주목되는 상황입니다.
어 배경은 아까 말씀드렸던 대로 어
카니 총리의 세계 캐나다를 세계
최고의 데이터 센터 건설 국가로 내
하겠다는 어떤 슬로건하고 메타디니지가
마물렸다는 것이고요. [콧방귀] 어
작년에 그래서 엘버타주의 전력 산업
규제를 완화했다고 합니다. 미국 같은
경우는 데이터 센터 지을 때 뭐 환경
규제나 주민들의 반발이나 뭐 이런
것들 때문에 좀 지연되고 있다고
하는데 어 캐나다 같은 경우는 어
그런 규제 자체를 좀 완화하는 걸로
봐서 앞으로 그 데이터 센터를
짓는 하나의 뭐 그 주요한 메인
사이트로
하다가 발도 좀 하지 않을까라는
생각이 들었고 시사점은 전문님도 좀
언지를 해 주셨지만 어 캐나다대
데이터 센터 투자가 어 단순히 내부
AI 인프라 확충을 넘어서 어 메타가
장기적으로 외부 고객의 AI 컴퓨팅을
판매하는 클라우드 사업자 역할까지
염두해 두고 있다는 걸로 어 봐서
이달 초에 시장의 변동성을 일으켰던
네러티브가 메타가 남는 AI 컴퓨팅
용량을 팔 수 있다였고 그 말이
내부적으로 인연 인프라가 있다는
뜻으로 해석돼서 지금까지 공격적인
AI 케펙스가 수요 대비 과했을 을
수 있고 따라서 AI 인프라에 대한
모멘텀이 둔화될 수 있다는 우려가
있었는데 이번에 캐나다 데이터 센터
투자 확대는 메타의 AI케펙스 인프라
축소 우려를 좀 부식시키는 거
같고요. 메타의 데이터 센터이 그
클라우드 서비스 비즈니스 확장 위지를
어 확 확인시켜 주면서 기존 서비스
사업자인 마이크로소프트, 아마존,
구글 등 아 기존 사업자들과 경쟁이
좀 예상될 거 같고 예상되고 있고
클라우드 사업 서비스 사업자들끼리 어
경쟁 역할은 다시 AI 인프라 투자
확대로 이어질 가능성까지 어 생각해
볼 수 있지 않나라고 보고 있습니다.
그래서 투자 관점에서는 메타의 AI
투자를 과수화할 수 과속화할 수
있다는 사실이 증명되었고 강한 수요가
지속되는 한 클라우드 서비스
사업자들도 투자 확대 가능성은 증가될
걸로 보여지고요. 어 최근에 뱅크
오브 아메리카에서에
그 하이퍼스케일러들의
케펙스 투자에 대해서 다지 업데이트
했는데 메타 쪽만 특별히 봤고요.
다른 사업자들도 어 계속해서 증가시켜
주는 그 추정치를 상향하는 모습이
뱅크 아메리카에서 보였고 어 메타의
케펙스 추정이 블룸버그하고 지금음
뱅커 아메리카 추정상으로 보면은
26년에 135 20 근데 아 이게
블룸버그 주정이 135였고
어
다시 뱅커 오메리카가 145로
이전 추정치를 어 높인 결과치가 한
10년 정도 차이가 나고요.
27년에는 블룸버그 추정은 162.
그리고 뱅크메리는 185. 28년은
178에서
어 그 뱅커메니 210으로 어
계속해서
이런 상향 조정이 나타날지 아니면은
어 뱅크 오메리카만의 추 그 생각일지
모르겠지만 어 어쨌든 뱅크 오메리카가
선재적으로 어 추정치 상향을 다른들
대비해서 빨리 어 올렸습니다.
지금 메타가
PR은 한 14.6배
거래가 되고 있고요. 계속해서 이제
케펙스를 본격적으로 하다 보면은
주가는 사실은 그 박스권 내지는 조금
그 밸리에이션 축소로 조금 더
이어지지 않을까라는 생각이 들어서 어
투자 관점에서는 뭐 이거와는 상관없이
AI 인프라 쪽에서는 더 힘을 받을
걸로 보고 있습니다. 그래서 어
클라우드 사업자들의 이제 전방 수요
상황을 아 그나마 좀 살펴볼 수
있는게 밑에 클라우드 시장 현황에서
어 기업별 클라우드 어 사업의
어 점유율인데
일단 잘 아시다시피 마이크로소프트
아마존님 어 1등 사업자로서 28%를
어 차지하고 있고 마이크로소프트
에저어가 21% 어 구글 클라우드가
14%로 로 예전에 이제 한
자릿수에서 어 두 자릿수로 껑충
띄었습니다. 그다음에는 고만고만하게
어 오라클이 한 4% 알리바바가 4%
그리고 셀즈 포스 어 화웨이 뭐
텐센트 이런 식으로 돼 있고요.
26년 1큐 1분기 기준 매출
상으로 나타난 클라우드 사업자들의
점유율이고요. 참고로 26년 1분기에
분기 기준으로 어 전체 매출은
클라우드 전체 매출은 129빌리언
달러 어 정도입니다. 그래서
대략적으로 뭐 어 한 요걸 4를
곱하면 한 500빌리언 달러 내외
정도의 어 시장 규모라고 보시면 될
거 같고요. 근데 중요한 거는 옆에
어 클라우드 서비스 시장 규모하고
성장률을 보면은 어 2023년 3Q를
기준으로 볼 때 그 성장률 자체가 어
꺾이다가 어 2023년 3Q 기준으로
지금 가속화되고 있습니다. 그래서 매
분기 보면은 그때 당시에 이제 한
18%에서 어 지금 분기별 Yy
성장률이 36%까지 올라갔습니다.
그래서 수요 자체는 상당히 단단한
걸로 어 보여지고 있고 어
2030년까지 대략적으로 30에서 한
40% 정도의 성장률을 어 기록할
걸로 어 리서치 기관마다 좀 다르긴
하지만 어 그 정도의 컨센서스를
이루고 있는 거 같습니다.
그래서 기업별로 상위 4계사 중에서
어이 클라우드 서비스 관련된 어 매출
성장을 좀 뭐 25년하고 26년 어
2개년 정도 보면은 어 아마존이 1등
사업자인데 120빌년
정도를 25년에 했고요. 어 올해 한
167빌년 정도가 예상이 되고
있습니다. 한 Yi로 한 30%
정도요. 그리고 마이로소프트
클라우드가 25년에 106빌리 정도
했고 26년에 137빌리언으로
한 30% 내 정도의
성장을 보일 걸로 어 예상이 되고
있고 어 구글 클라우드가 어 굉장히
비약적으로 어 성장을 하고 있는데 어
25년 매출이 20 58.7빌리언에서
26년에 96.8빌리언까지 8빌리까지
어 올라올 걸로 예상이 되고 있고
Yi 성장률은 65%입니다. 그리고
오라클라우드 같은 경우 25년
34빌년에서 어 26년 56빌년으로
66% 성장을이
예상이 되고 있습니다. 이거는 오픈
AI 관련된 계약이 많이 반영되면서
앞으로도 성장률이 좀 어 강해질 거
같고요.
그래서 전반적으로 보면은 어 클라우드
비즈니스의 앞단의 수요 자체는 어
30% 중후반 정도로 계속 좀
가수화되는 상황에서 어 클라우드
사업자들 우리가 흔히 얘기하는 하이퍼
스케일러들의 어 인프라 투자도 어
계속적으로 늘어날 걸로 예상이 되는
가운데 여기에 그 메타는 자체 그
AI 인프라만 구축하다가
공격적으로 어 클라우드 비즈니스 에
뛰어든다면
그 하이퍼스케일러들 간의 어 경쟁은
더 심화가 되지 않을까? 그러면
결국에는 어 월초에 있었던 어 AI
인프라 축소 우려는 조금 어 완화되지
않을까 아 이런 생각입니다.
이상입니다.
예. 지금
근데 위에 클라우드 서비스 시장 규모
및 성장률 있잖아요.
>> 예예.
>> 이게 글로벌 전체 월드와이드 마켓
사이즈라고 돼 있는 거 맞죠? 예,
그렇습니다. 옆에 보시면은 어 그
옆차트에 클라우드 클라우드
인프라스트럭처앤
Q1 2026 있잖아요. 이게
[목을 가다듬음] 토탈
129빌년입니다.
1분기에
>> 예 1분기 한 분기에 한분기에
>> 예 그래서 옆에 이제 어 이것도
26년 1분기까지 표시가 돼
있잖아요. 좌측의
거가 이제 규모고요. 절대 x고
우측의 거가 yyy 성장률인데 좌측에
보면 이제 131년 근처로 막대
그래프가 돼 있잖아요. 그
>> 예. 예. 그래서 그요 전체요
기업들의 점유율하고요 기업들의 어
2026년 1분기 매출 합쳐보니까
129빌년 정도 나왔는데 아 그거는
어 그 yy로 한 36% 정도 어
늘어난 수치다 이렇게 보시면 되는데
어 그 성장률 자체가 분기별로 계속
가속화되고 있는 그런 상황입니다. 어
야이 표를 보니깐 2020년 21년
22년 요렇게 넘어갈 때는 이로스
레이트 성장률이
정도에서 밑으로 쭉 떨어지고 있었는데
>> 예
>> 23년 하반기부터 다시 성장률이
가파르게 올라가는게 이게 AI
때문이죠. 그죠?
>> 예.
정확하게 22년 4분기에
어 11월에 그 오픈 AI가 채지를
내놨잖아요. 예. 그러면서 점점점 또
그시기 지금부터 해서 어 가속화되는
그런 모습인 거 같습니다. 어
한 분기에 어 130 빌리언이니까
이게 또 30% 넘는 성장률을 보이고
있고 그래서 제가 대충 계산해 봤더니
올해 내년 그거 가면 한 700조
700빌리안이니까
거의 1조 시장이에요.
>> 예 그렇습니다. 엄청난 시장이
되네요. 음.
그리고
아마존하고 마이크로소프트
요렇게 둘이 합쳐서 50%
알파벳 구글이 15% 정도까지
올려보고 있고
>> 밑에 오라크 알리바바바지폴스
뭐 하웨이 텐센트 이렇게 밑으로 쭉
있는데
상위 상계사가 60한 4% 정도
>> 그렇습니다. 니다.
>> 이렇게 굳어지는 거다. 그죠?
>> 예. 이렇게 굳어지고 메타가 여기에서
이제 어떻게 할지가 반건인 거
같습니다.
>> 아직까지는 메타의 존재감이 지금은
없는 거잖아요.
>> 전혀 없죠. 왜냐하면은 클라우드
서비스 안 하고 있었고 내부, AI,
인프라 확충에만 신경을 썼는데 이번에
>> 어,
>> 클라우드 판매까지 하겠다고 선언을 한
거죠.
>> 어.
어제 메타 주가는 빠졌잖아요.
>> 예, 빠졌습니다.
>> 그러니까 이렇게
어떻게 보면 공고해져 있는이
빅도 있고 그 밑에 또 막 4% 2%
이런 기업들도 만만치 않은 기업들이
다 포진에 있는데
>> 예.이
>> 메타가 클라우드 클라우드 서비스를
하겠다.이
후발주자로.
>> 예.
>> 그 그래서 약간 야 후발 주자로 지금
뛰어들어서 되겠어? 뭐 약간 그렇게
평가한 건가요? 그렇게 어쨌든
>> 그 메타가 투자를 공격적으로 한다고
발표할 때마다
시선 자체는
>> 이전에 이제 메타버스에 대한 기억이
있어 가지고 그 트라우마가 있어
가지고
>> 어 그
성과를 못 냈던 기억들이 남아 있는
거 같아요. 그래서 이번에도 좀 어
공격적으로 어떻게 얼마나 잘할지에
대한 관망심리 내지는 우려가 조금
존재하지 않나 싶습니다.
>> 예. 그러
>> 예. 기존에 어 그 메타가 인연
인프라를 판다고 했을 때 8%가
올랐었잖아요.
>> 그때 자체 시장 심리는 어 메타가
추가적으로 더 투자를 하지 않고 남는
거 팔면서 좀 효율을 하지 않겠나?
어 이런 심리가 강했다면 어제 나왔던
어
캐나다의 데이터 센터 확대 얘기는
조금 결이 다른 거 같습니다.
>> 근데 아까 그 캐나다지도 보면서
>> 야
>> 저 광화란 땅에 그죠?
>> 예. 엄청난 또 뭐이
최근에 우리나라 반도체 공장 뭐
얘기할 때도 용수
>> 예
>> 물이 부족하고 어쩌고 뭐 그런 얘기가
있었는데
>> 저쪽 5대
그쪽 위로 온타리오치 방에 보면 또
엄청난 여기 허더슨 베이라고 돼
있네요.
>> 예.
>> 그러니까 캐나다는이 데이터 센터 하면
되겠죠.
>> 예. 그러니까요.
>> 미국하고 바로 가깝게 또 있으니까
>> 알겠습니다. 메타의
>> 캐나다 첫 데이터 센터 투자 발표에
대해서 또 꼼꼼하게 짚어 주셨습니다.
그러면 어 근데 오늘 전체이 클라우드
시장이 어떻게 되는지이 마켓 사이즈를
[목을 가다듬음] 제가 몰랐었는데
>> 어 마켓 사이즈 클라우드 시장 천조
>> 천조의
>> 어 Y로스는 지금 계속 가파르게
올라가면서 30% 넘는 고성장이
지속되고 있다.
>> 요렇게 기억하고 넘은 관계
>> 예. 예. 그러니까 이제 메타
입장에서도이 고성장하고 있는 사업에
뛰어드는 거죠.
자체적으로 뭐 이거저거 해보다 안
되니까
그런 거 같습니다.
알겠습니다.
자 그러면 어 국내 시장으로 넘어가
보도록 하겠습니다.네
전일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
어 코스피 지수 5.3% 하락
마감했었고요. 코스닥이 5.5% 5%
하락 마감하면 하면서 전일 시장
분위기 굉장히 험악하게 빠졌었던
하루였고요.
MSC 사우스 코리아 ETF 봐
주시면 어제 0.8% % 상승으로
마감을 했습니다. 약간 선물이 좀
강한 반등세를 보였는데요. 한 4%
올라가면서 오늘 시초가는 좀 강하게
시작하지 않을까 생각이 들고요.
수급적으로 보면 개인 투자자 350억
매도가 나왔습니다. 아까 말씀해 주신
대로 반대 매매 영향이 뭐 좀 있었던
거 같고요. 외국인 투자자가 어제
매수로 전환을 했는데요. 많은 금액을
매수한 건 아니지만 그래도
3,300억 가량 매수세가 유입이
됐습니다. 기관에서는 3,억 대도
나오면서 기관 쪽은 여전히 매도세가
유지가 되고 있는 상황이고요. 외인
선물에서는 매수가 좀 그래도 강하게
들어왔던 거 같은데요. 1조 6천억
매수세 유입됐습니다.
투자자별 매매 동향 보면 어제 외국인
투자자 SK이닉스,
삼성전기,
LG 이노텍, SK퀘어, HD
현대중공업, 현대차, 한미 반도체
등을 매수를 했었고요. 외국인
매도에는 삼성전자, 삼성전자 우선주,
하나오션, LIG, DNA, APL,
KB 금융 등을 매도했습니다. 기관
매수에는 s 어 삼성전자 SK 아
삼성전자 우선주 기아 KB 금융 등을
매수를 했었고요. 매도 쪽에는
SK이닉스 삼성전기
LG 이노텍 LS1렉 현대 중공업
등을 어 매도를 했습니다. 최근에
보니까 외국인들이 삼성전기를 좀 계속
매수하더라고요.
최근에 많이 빠지는데 계속 그래도 한
1천억 단위로 벨스가 유입이고 그래서
궁금해서 한 60일h치 데이터를
보니까 외국인 순매수 상위가 삼성
전기가 1등이고요. 어 보니까 한
1조 6천억가량
매수했고 그다음이 현대 로템 두산
포스홀딩 셀즈 엔솔 SDI 이런
순입니다.
>> 어제 외국인 매수 금액 저거는 100
70억인가요? 아니면
>> 170원입니다.
>> 1570이네. [목을 가다듬음]
여기에 열배에 해당되는 금액을 최근에
60일 동안 샀단 말이죠.
>> 네. 그리고 52주 신고가 종목네
종목입니다. 코스피에서 사무 개발 어
다스코가 신고가였고요. 코스닥은
C랩 그리고 데이터 솔루션 이렇게
신고가를 기록을 했는데 어 다스코랑
데이터 솔루션은 어제 호재성 공시들이
있었고 수주 계약 소식들이 좀 크
굵직굵직한게 있었더라고요. 그래서
시가총에 작은 종목이지만 시장이 저런
상황에서도 상한가를 기록을 했습니다.
전부 시총 1100억, 1천억,
1천억, 964억.
예. 요런게 없게 되네요.
외국인이 보니까 하이닉스는 샀고
전자는 팔았네요.
[목을 가다듬음]
하이닉스 쪽으로는 뭐 ADR 쪽에 한
열배 정도 되는 자금이 몰렸다.
>> 네. 어, 요렇게 나오더라고요.
그리고 공무가가
최근 3일 평균가로 뭐 결정된다든
공무가 결정된 거예요.
>> 제가 그 부분을 확인은 하지
못했는데요. 확인해 못했습니다.
공무가를 낮추기 위해서 일부러 뭐
외국인이 눌렀다 뭐 이러는데
>> 그거는 좀 우리가 항상 좀 조심해야
될게
>> 외국인이 외국인 한 명만 있는게
아니에요. 어 기관이 일부러 주가를
뭐 올리고 기관이 일부러 주가를 빼고
>> 그것도 기관도 수백개의 기관이
있거든요. 그래서 그런 짓을 하면
다른 기관에서 어 올려 주네
때려야지. 어 밀어 주네 사야지.
이렇게 되기 때문에 외국인이 뭐
억지로 밀고 당기고
그런 거는 좀 아니다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 어제 같은 경우에도 외국인은
어 하이닉스는 한 1,600억 정도
사긴 샀습니다. 열배가 몰렸다면
이번에 조달하는 자금이 45조잖아요.
예. 45년대 그러면 450조금
몰렸다는 말씀
맞습니다. 예.
>> 그리고 어제 워맨 심박인가 뭐
댓글에서 어 환율이 왜 떨어지냐 그런
얘기도 했었는데이
45조라는 자금이 조달되는 거기
때문에
>> 어 달러로 조달돼서 그 조달된
자금으로 국내에다가
어 투자한다라고 한 거 아니에요.
그죠?
>> 예. 그렇습니다.
>> 그러면 그 조달한 자금을 원화로
이렇게 바꿔서 국내 투자해야 되기
때문에
>> 일시적으로 꽤 큰 금액이에요.
>> 예, 맞습니다.
>> 꽤 큰 금액이 들어오는 거기 때문에
영향을 좀 이런 자금이 큰 자금이
들어올 거니까 미리
줄어보였고 어제는 외국인이 보시다시피
어 샀습니다. 코스피뿐만 아니라
코스닥 그리고 선물
>> 그리고 어제 옵션 보다 보니까 풋
옵션을 400몇억을 왕창 때렸더라고
>> 그 풋 옵션 왕창 때리는 걸 보고
>> 어 오늘 시장은 반등이구나 그렇게
신차 분석에서 말씀드리기 했었는데
야간 선물이 플 4% 예 올라가서
시초가는 아마 플러스 한 2.5에서
3.5
이 정도 시작하지 않을까?요
종목들 동영 한번 쭉 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 반도체 섹터 맞추시면 어제 대용
반도체가 또다시 급락을 하면서 뭐
소부장까지도
큰폭 하락세를 기록했던 하루였는데요.
삼성전자가 6% 하락 마감했고
SK하이닉스가 5.7%
큰 포기의 하락세를 기록을 했습니다.
뭐 장초에 플러스 흐름까지도 갔었던
걸로 기억이 나고 지수 자체도 한 플
1%까지
갔었는데 결국에는 또 매도 물량들이
많이 나오면서 시장은 굉장히 약하게
마감을 했었던 거 같습니다. 어,
소부장 종목들 봐 주시면 HPSP,
이오테크, 주성 엔지니어링 등의
장비주들이 대체로 7% 넘는 하락률을
기록을 했었고요. 아리 기판이나 뭐
소재 쪽도 낙폭이 상당히 컸습니다.
기판 쪽에 대덕 전자, 이수페타
9%대 급락세를 보였고요. 그리고
소재 쪽에 솔브레인도 한 4%대
하락세를 기록을 했습니다.
어, IT 섹터 봐 주시면 어제
삼성전기가 10% 급락이 나왔습니다.
어, 밸루에이션이 순식간에 50배까지
떨어져 있는 상황이고요. 최근에 한
80배가 넘었었던 걸로 기억이 나는데
50배까지 떨어졌습니다. 어, 그리고
LG 전자 LG 디스플레이가 3%대
올랐던 건 특징적이었던 거 같고요.
플랫폼 섹터는 어 네이버가
2%대, 카카오도 2%대 하락하면서
어 플랫폼 좀 부진했습니다. 니케이
지수 전일장의 2%대 약세로
마감했는데요. 여기도 비슷합니다.
반도체 IT 섹터가 안 좋았는데 도쿄
일렉트론 3%, 호야 6%, 뭐
디스코 2비덴, 어드반 테스트 등이
약세 흐름을 보였습니다.
네. 자동차 섹터 봐 주시면 어제
기하는 상승세를 그래도 보였었고요.
어, 반면에 현대차나 현대 오토에버
등은 또 약세름을 보이기도 했습니다.
소비제 섹터 봐 주시면 어제 생건
아몰에 그저께 많이 올랐었는데
전일장에는 어 [콧방귀] 하락으로
마감하는 모습이었고요.
화장품 OEM ODM도 약세였습니다.
피우 미용기 쪽도 그저께 좋았었는데
전일장에서는 대체로 약세 흐름으로
마감을 하는 모습이었고요.
어 아래 음식 섹터에서 행시품도
그저께 11% 급등세를 보였다가
전일장에는 상승분을 일부 반납하는
모습이 나타났습니다.
최근에 백화점 주가가 좀 안
좋은데요. 신세계가 8% 현대
백화점이 4% 하락했습니다. 그래서
업항 자체나 최근에 나오는 데이터들
보면 외국인 방문객수 이런게 다 좋은
상황이거든요. 근데 밸루에이션이 한
17배까지 신세계가 갔다가 다시
14배까지 좀 착해진 상황이라서
오히려 이럴 때는 매수 찬스로
활용해도 되지 않나라는 생각입니다.
조선 철감및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
조선주들 안 좋았습니다. 하나 우선이
그저께 22% 급락이 나왔었는데
전일장에서 추가 또 급락이 나오면서
어 주가 흐름 자체가 완전히
꺾였다라고 단기적으로 좀 볼 수 있을
것 같고요. 포워드 밸류가 14배
수준이라서 성장성이 아예 없는
회사급으로 밸류가 많이 내려오는
상황이다 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
그리고 아래 철강이나 화학 섹터
보진했고 어제 전쟁 노예지가 좀 있다
보니 장중인 유가가 급락과 급등을 좀
하는 모습이 나왔었고 S이 영향을
받았던 거 같습니다. 방산주들도 어제
굉장히 안 좋았습니다. 뭐 특별한
악재 이런 건 없었는데요. 하나
에어로가 7%, 넥스온이 10%
급락했고 현대 로템이 9% 급락이
나왔습니다. 여기도 많이
착해졌습니다. 넥스원이 60배까지 그
1과 미국 간의 전쟁이 격화됐을 때
6, 70배까지 갔었다가 34배까지
빠져 있는 상황이고요. 로템은 뭐
20배를 깬지는 좀 됐습니다. 그
바이오섹터 어제 안 좋았습니다.
산바나 에피스 대체로 부진한
흐름이었고요.
음. 음, 삼성 바이오 밸루에이션 안
본지 좀 오래됐었는데 30배까지
내려온 상황이더라고요. 밸류가 이렇게
낮은 회사는 아니었던 거 같은데 많이
낮아진 상황이고 아래 코스닥 바이오도
안 좋았습니다. 알테오젠, 에이
바이오, 펩트론 대체로 약세였고요.
코스닥 바이오도 다 안 좋았습니다.
어제 은행주는 그래도 시장 대비로
탄탄한 흐름 그리고 키움 증고도이
정도면 뭐 나쁘진 않았습니다. 엔터
쪽은 하이브가 오전장에 플러스름을
보이다가 시장이 밀리다 보니 0.8%
8% 하락으로 마감을 했고요. 뭐
나머지 엔터 조절도 무진했습니다.
변합기의 낙폭이 굉장히 큽니다. 어
현대 1렉 조성 중고 LS 1일렉
대체로 한 7% 이상 하락세를
보였습니다. 그래서 초선 그리고
방산이 변합기 그런 산업제 쪽이 사실
올해 상반기까지는 그래도 괜찮음이
있었던 거 같은데 이번 달 들어서
그리고 6월 말부터 굉장히 주가
흐름이 안 좋아진 상황인 거
같습니다.
>> 어제 시장 분위기가 허막했다 그죠?
>> 예. [목을 가다듬음]
그리고 꼭 바닥에서는이
우리나라 개인 투자자분들이
어 떨어질 때 원래 잘 사고 올라갈
때 잘 팔고
그냥 빠지면 사고 올라가면 파나 3
5판 잘 하시는데이
마지막이 페닉셀링 국면에서는
말 그대로이 반대 매매 반대 매매가
나오면서 좀 안타깝죠.이 이 정작 좀
사야 되는 가격대에 도달했을 때는
어쩔 수 없는 반대 매매가 나오고
그면에서 보면 외국인들이 또 오히려
사요.
최근에 보니까 외국인 선물이 여기만
딱 봐도요
3일 전 1조 매도한 거 빼고는
거죠.
>> 네. 계속 여기서 이제 매수하고
있어요.
그리고 주식 매수가 이제 들어와야
되는데 어제 3,300억 정도 이렇게
매수 들어왔고
푸스에서 아까 400억 이상 매도
때렸다했잖아요. 그 400억 이상
매도는 어제 신규 매도라기보다는 품
매수 산 놨던게 큰 폭으로 이익이
나니까
>> 거기서 이익 실현한
>> 예. 400억이라고 보면 되기 때문에
이렇게 또
외국인 옵션 플레이어들한테 또 약간
틀리는 거 같아 보는 부분들 좀
찍겠는데
자 어 종목들 동량 받고요. 그리고
종목들 막 무너지는 거 보면 어 정말
살 주식이 많아지고 있습니다.
지수도 착해졌어요. 9,300을
찍었던 지수가 7,200이 됐고
YTD로 122%까지 갔었거든요.
>> 네.
>> 그래서 뭐 고점 대접이 저거 20%
빠지면 그게 실제로는 40% 날아가는
거다. 뭐 그런 얘기를 했었는데
>> 지금 이제 YTD로 71. 무력이니까
120%에서 72%가 돼서니까
얼마예? 50% 난리 먹은 거죠.
그죠? 고점 대비해서는
10% 그동안에 수익을 냈던 걸 날려
먹었다고 보면 되는데 그런데 아 그거
내가 챙겼어야 되는데
[목을 가다듬음] 그런 생각 안
하셔도 된다는 게
>> 음네
>> 시장이 생각보다 내제 가치 대비해서
많이 빠지기도 하고 그 내제 가치
대비해서 생각보다 더 올라가기도
해요.
>> 네. 그래서 그 오버슈팅 국면은 꼭
굳이 내 몫시라고 안 보시는게
맞습니다. 그러니까 종목별로도
마찬가지일 겁니다. 종목별로도 아
먹은 먹은 거 다 빼네.
그게요
중간 선거가 있는 애요 789가 원래
좀 험악한
갑자기 겨울이 오는 그런 부분이라고
생각하시면 되고 이번 걸 계기로 어
메모를 해 놓으시면 돼요. 매물를 해
놓으셔서 최근에 6월 달, 5월 달에
막 주식 사시는 분들 그 겨울이
오는데 막 묘종에다가
>> 네.
>> 시 씨 뿌리는 거래요. 씨 뿌리는거나
마찬가지예요. 겨울이 막 인박했는데
거기에다가 봄에 나는 나물, 상추,
고추 막 씨뿌리는 잘못된
타이밍했다.
좀 그렇게 보시면 되고.
그리고 이렇게
주가가 빠지면
이제 먹을 주식이 너무 많아지죠.
6개월 농사 짓는다고 생각하게 하고
들어가도
먹을 주식이 여기서는 이제는 30%
낼 수 있을 것 같은데 1년이면
그죠?요
>> 정도 가격 되면
>> 30% 수익이 나올 것 같아.
또
주식의 이제 변동성. 그리고 그
변동성을 이야기하는 마지막 패닉산
국면에는 어 신용 반대 매매도 나오고
그다음에
뭐 프랍 데스크 이런 데서도 요즘은
증권사 프라이도
아직도 맞나? 요즘 거의 많이 없어진
거 같은데
>> 최근에는 못 들었던 거 같아요.
>> 그렇죠. 네. 옛날에는 정권사가
어 그
거저갱가 어떤 분이 룰브레이커
님이셨나? 브로크리지가 뭐예요라는
질문을 어셨는데
정권사가 하는 주요 업무가 세
가지거든요. 예. 매매 수수료를
먹는. 근데 매매를 중개해 주게 이제
브로컬이죠. 그다음에 두 번째가 인수
주관 업무. 예. 신주 발행해 주고
최사체 발행해 주고 그 업무
언더라이팅 업무라고 세 번째 업무가
자기 매매 딜링 업무가 있습니다.
정권사 고유 자금으로 딜링
이게 35년 전에
>> 음
>> 주식 소급자 중급자 볼 때
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 나왔던 내용인데 근데 정권사가 이제는
업무가 많아졌어요.
>> 신탁 업무도 있고 뭐
>> 많아졌습니다. 인베스먼 뱅크
역할에다가 많아졌는데
그래서 자기 딜링이 있었는데 요즘은
자기 딜링 안 하는 거 같아요.
왜냐면 워낙 리테일 마켓이 좋아지면서
>> 뭐 랩 상품이든 뭐든 거기서 뭐
>> 돈을 쫙쫙 벌어 가니까
>> 환전 업무도 생겼잖아요.
>> 해 주식 가는 거에 대해서.
그래서 최근에이 증권주도 쭉 빠지고
있잖아요.이 증권주도 좀
빠지면 벌써이 가격대는 매력적인
가격이 됐고 단지 이제 진입 시점이
뭐 키움 정권 저기 5.6배 이래
나오잖아요. 그죠?
저런 것들은이
9월에서 10월 딱치고 이제 돌았을
때 그럴 때가
또 매수해 볼 만한 그런 가격대로
주고 있고 사고 싶은 주식이 한두
개가 아닙니다.
자, 어 리포트 한번 볼 텐데 오늘은
종목 리포트를 들고 오셨네요. APR
아, APR하고
하이닉스
APR 리포터부터 먼저 보겠습니다.
APR도 최근에 주가 변동성이 좀
많이 커진 상황인데
어, 차트를 보니까 APR은 고점
대비 한 15% 빠졌더라고요. 근데
사실 개별 종목이 15%밖에 안
빠졌으면 상당히 강했다라고도
볼 수 있을 것 같은데 일단 내용을
좀 살펴보겠습니다.
어, 하나 한유정 연구원 자료였고요.
2분기에 대한 어 실적 리뷰
자료입니다. 26분기 APR의 연결
매출은 7,500억대 전망을 했고요.
영업 이익 1800억 전망을
했습니다. 그래서 컨센서스 이익이
1674억인데이를
좀 상할 것으로 보고 있는 거
같고요. 전 지역에서 판매 호조가
이어진 가운데 미국과 유럽의 성장이
특히 두드러지게 나타났을 것 같다라는
전망입니다. 미국쪽 코멘트를 보면
아마존과 틱톡에서의 판매 호조뿐만
아니라 뭐 타겟이나 월마트 등
오프라인 채널 확장이 순조롭게 진행이
되면서 매출액은 3,534억이
나올 것으로 추정을 했고요. 신성장
국가 쪽으로 보면 중앙권 재외 신성장
국가 매출액은 2,457억
나오면서 미국뿐만 아니라 신성장 국가
쪽에서도 좋은 거 같습니다. yy
208% 증가표로도 약 30% 정도
증가한 것으로 추정을 했습니다.
연초부터 본격화된 유럽 직접 사업
확대가 기대 이상의 성가로 이어지고
있다라고 하고요. 다만 OPM으로
보면 24.5% 5% 정도로 추정을
했는데 YY로 1.3% 포인트 빠졌을
거로 보고 있고요. QQ로도 1.2%
포인트 하락했을 것으로 전망을
했습니다. 전이 종전 추정시 대비
소폭 하락한 것으로 추정을 하는데
예상보다 큰 물류비부담이 반영된
영향으로 판단한다 이야기를 했습니다.
성장의 폭에 의미를 둘 시점이다라는
의견인데요. 지정학적 리스크로 해상
운송 리드 타임이 기루어진 상황에서
빠르게 증가하는 소유에 대응하기 위해
항공 운송을 확대한 영향으로 2분기에
좀 비용이 어 부용 부담이 컸다라고
하고 그러나 일시적인 운인 부담보다
예상치를 뛰어넘는 외형 성장의 의미를
볼 필요가 있겠다라는 의견이고요.
미국에서는 기존 스테디러를 중심으로
해상운송 전환이 진행이 되고 있다라고
하고요. 생산 제공이 물류 체계가
안정화될수록 한국운송 비중은 점차
낮자실 전망이다. 단기 부의용
부담에도 영업 이익은 매분기 사상
최대치를 경신할 것으로 보고 있고요.
향후 공급망사가 진행될수록 높은 매출
성장이 이익 증가로 연결되는 폭 역시
확대될 것이다. 투자기론 바이 타겟
프라이스 50만 원으로 유지를
했습니다. 어 2분기 실제의 절대
수준이 높았던만큼 3분기는 전분기
대비 성장에 대한 단기적인 부담이
부학될 것으로 판단을 한다. 다만
상반기를 통해 미국 온라인 오프라인
채널 확장과 유럽 초기 침투 성과가
동시에 확인했다라고 하고요. 신규
SKU나 카테고리 확장도 순도롭게
진행되고 있다. 그래서 2분기에 높은
실적 기초로 3분기는 단기적인 성장률
부담이 어 좀 부각이 될 수도
있겠지만 상반기에 확인된 지역 채널
확장의 성과가 누적되면서 성수기인
4분기에는 매출의 절대 수익이 다시
한번 높아질 가능성이 있다. 긍정적인
돈으로 이야기를 한 거 같고요. 현재
주가가
38만 원입니다. 그러니까 타겟
프라이스 50만 원 정도로 제시한 거
같고요.
>> 아래 실적 추정 자료로 보면 뭐
AP는 이거 볼 때마다 좀 신기할
정도로 실적이 좋긴 한데요. 올해
예상 매출액이 2조 9천억 전망 되고
있습니다. 뷰티 디바이스 화장품
이렇게 두 가지목으로
나뉘는데요. 뷰티 디바이스도
뭐 나쁘진 않은 거 같아요. 보시면
2024년에
어 3,130억 그리고
2025년에 4,억 그리고 26년에
5,500억 정도가 뷰티 디바이스에서
나올 것으로 추정이 되고 있고요. 뭐
성장률로 보면 나쁘지 않은
상황입니다. 화장품 쪽으로 내려가서
보면 24년 3,390억, 25년
1조 그리고 26년 2조
3,억입니다. 그래서 화장품 성장이
놀라울 정도로 계속해서 강하게 나오고
있다라는 것을 볼 수 있을 것
같고요. 화장품 쪽 보면 화 한국
쪽은 오히려 올해 감소입니다. 근데
미국 쪽이
>> 지난해 4,800억인데 올해 1조
2,억이 미국에서만 나온다라는 걸 알
수가 있고요. 일본 쪽 성장도 굉장히
좋은 거 같아요. 24년에 270억
그리고 25년에 100억 그리고 올해
1,570억으로
일본 쪽에서도의 성장이 좀 가파르게
나오고 있는 상황이고요. 신성장
국가도 이렇게 좋은 줄는 저는 잘
몰랐었는데
24년에 940억 그리고 지난해
3,500억 올해가 8,800억
수준입니다. 그래서 굉장히 화장품
쪽의 상상이 가파르게 나타나고
있다라고 볼 수 있는 거 같고요.
영업 이익률을 보면 오른쪽 표에
하단에 있습니다. 어,
연간으로 봐야 되니까 맨 오른쪽으로
가서 봐 주시면 영업 이익률이
202년 17%,
25년 24%, 그리고 올해가
25.1% 1%
추정이 되어 있습니다. 그래서 영업
이익률도 뭐 상승폭 자체는 둔화된 건
맞는 거 같아요. 24에서 25
넘어갈 때 이때 수출 비중이 워낙 확
확대가 되다 보니 어 마진이 저렇게
좋아졌고 올해는 좀 내려온다곤 하지만
어쨌든 1% 포인트 정도 맞은 계선은
유지가 될 거다. 추정치가 깔려 있는
거 같습니다.
비슷한 흐름이죠. 확실히 보면 수출
비중 터질 때 영업 이익률이 뭐 4%
포인트 5% 포인트 올라갔다가 수출
쪽은 계속 좋지만 이제 비중 자체는
더 이상 늘어날 룸이 없는 상황에서나
1, 2% 포인트 정도의 어 상승세가
나타나는데 어 AP도 비슷한 흐름인
거 같습니다. 그래서 밸루에이션이
지금 한 23배 정도의 거래가 되고
있어서 뭐 이익 증가나 PG 관점으로
보면 저렴한 건 맞는데이 화장품
쪽이나 피 미용 기기 쪽에 대한
밸류를 시장에서 높게 쳐주면 30배고
좀 평탄할 때 25배 좀 성장성이
꺾였을 때는 요즘 한 15배 정도까지
내려서 보는 거 같긴 한데 APR
23배면
지금 시장 상황으로 봤을 때 비싸지도
싸지도 않은 느낌이 들거든요. 음.
>> 네.
>> 근데 이제 주가 자체는 확실히 탄탄한
모습으로 움직이고 있어서 좀 안정적인
자처 중에 하나지 않나는 생각이
>> 그래서이
소비제 중에서 제일 센 거 같아.
>> 네. 네.
>> 다른 것들은 고점 대비 뭐 35%
이렇게 빠지는 것도 많은데 APR은
그 안 빠
>> 박스권에서 그죠? 쫙 움직이고
비싸지도 싸지도 않다고 했는데이 좋은
주식을 싸게 살 기회를 안 주는
거죠. 그죠?
>> 좀 여기서 더 떨어지면 아 아무 걱정
없이 사겠는데 안 떨어지죠.
>> 20개면 그냥 사면 되는데 그런게
아니니까.
줄 꺼 놓고
이런 주식 보면 아 제발 좀 큰 조정
좀 와라 좀 사게 뭐 이런 느낌이
들잖아요. 그죠?
영업 이익률도 작년에 17%였다가
올해 23.9% % 내년에 25%
그리고이 매출액도 보면 계속 꾸준히
증가하고 있고 대단한 회사입니다.
영업 이익이 어30억
3,650억 7,400억
이게 10억 단위로 보면 되죠.네
네. 10억입니다. 음.
>> 왕박사고 봤을 때는이 왕박사랑
동갑이잖아.이
사장 88년생.이
>> APR의이 강점 어디서 있냐?
>> 마케팅.
>> 아, 마케팅.
>> 마케팅 효과도 좋고 그래서 플랜드
이미지도 잘 유지했어요.
>> 음. 그래서이기 때문에 그 해외로 잘
나가고 있는 상황이고요. 뭐 요즘에
그 환율도 좋으니까 그래서 환경은 다
조정되었어요. 그 실점 꽃빡꼬빠 알
수 있고 그리고 이분기 발생하는
비용는 아마 그거 이미 다
소화되었어요. 왜냐면 그인비는 지금
좀 얘기 거의 없고 그래서 3번기는
증상화 될 수 있지만 그 화전판 조금
보면 매출에는 2분기는 그냥 625
3분기는 619
>> 그 키우기는 줄이는 거는 잘 좀
한편을 봐야 하고요. 아마 뭐 이렇게
줄리면은 왜냐면 화점 마진율이
높잖아요. 이렇게 줄리면은 마진율이
빠질 수 가능성도 있긴 있는데 그런데
상황 좀 봐야 갖고요. 회자는 항선는
실접 시장 컨트스 대비는 좋게 나올
수 있으니까 그래서별 실적 잘
체크하고
>> 나쁘지 않다고 생각해요. 지금 멀티브
비슷하지 않으니까 디스크는 선대적으로
낫다고 생각해요.
나중에 그 코스닥 어떻게 되는지 얘기
좀 해 줄 때 어 샤움이 좀 어떻게
되는지
>> 아
>> 어 윤경민 님이 질문을 하셨는데
>> 네
>> 샤오미를 지켜보고 있는데 디행 가격이
꺾어야 한다고 말씀하셨는데 혹적인
설명 부탁드립니다. 쇼오미가
저가 제품 위주 사업이라면서 지형
가격이 높으면 낮은 제품 가격을
맞추기가 어렵다고 본화베이하게
설명해 주셨는데 코멘트 할 거 있는지
나중에 설명해 주시고
>> 자 하이닉스 가보겠습니다.네
>> BNK 이민이용구원 자료인데요. 어,
이민용구원님이
제가 기억하기로는 한국 아,
국내에서는 가장 빠르게 이제 반도체
의견을 꺾은
>> 애널리스트 중에 한 분이었거든요.
>> 어, 꽃건지
>> 몇 달 되죠?
>> 네. 한 저기 오른쪽에 그 아래 보면
이게 보유로 의견을 하향한게 26년
4월 27일이에요. 그래서
>> 어, 저 [콧방귀] 당시 닉스의
주가가 한 120만 원, 130만 원
했더라고요. 올해 4월 달쯤에. 네.
여기서 의견을 한번 꺾었었고 만약에
어떻게 될지 모르겠지만 하이닉스의
고점이 한 298만 원 정도가
고점이었다라고 만약에 된다면 어
이민연구 [콧방귀]
님은 한 왼쪽 허리 정도에서 이제
의견을 내렸다라고
>> 볼 수가 있는 건데 내용을 좀
살펴보겠습니다. 좀 보수적인
코멘트인데요.
>> 모멘텀이 두나 중에 있고 더 좋은
투자 기회를 기다리자라는 의견입니다.
AR 인프라 투자 속도 조절 가능성이
높아졌다라고 하는데요. A 서버양
디램이나 ESST는 아직 공급 무족시
왕에 있다. 그러나 주문을 제공하는
하이퍼스케일러들의 경제 경쟁적인
인프라 투사는 더 이상 유효하지는
않는다라고 하고요. 최근 메타가
프론티어 모델을 포기하고 잉여
인프라를 외부 판매로 돌렸는데 작은
조달 어려움과 성과 불확실성을 겪고
있는 다른 CSP들도 비슷한 상황일
것이다. 현재 미국 CSP들의 올해
케스 컨센서스는 YY 83%
증가고요. 내년은 23% 증가로 되어
있다라고 하는데 내년 메모리나 뭐
CPU 가격 상승 기대와 에이전트
AI 신모델들의 스펙 상향을 고려해
보면 내년에도 최소 30에서 40%
이상 설비 투자 증가가 필요해
보인다라고 합니다. 그러나 오히려
향후 투자 속도 조절 가능성이
높아지고 있어서 현재 반도체 기업의
실적 전망가는 괴리가 좀 있다라는
의견입니다. 그래서 내년에 이익
추정치부 UBS에서는 전자 800조
이익, 닉스 600조 이익 이렇게
분리시하게 보는 전망치들에 대해서는
좀 보수으로 봐야 되지 않나라는
의견인 거 같고요.
이번 AI 특수 사이클 이유가
걱정이라고 하는데요. 과거 다컴버블
특수를 계기로 대만 업체들이 대거
디램 시장에 들어바 있었는데 이번에는
AI 특수를 계기로 중국 업체들이
주요 PC나 모바일 OEM들 공급망에
본격 진입한 것으로 보여진다라고
하고요. 또한 메모리 상위 경쟁사들
간 수익성 격차도 더 이상 크지 않기
때문에 향후 다운 사이클 진입 시
후증이 좀 크지 않을까는 전망을
했습니다. 어 투자액는 보유 및 목표
주가 185만 원을 유지를 했는데요.
시크리컬 종목들은 사이클 고점에
접근할수록 저평가된 것처럼 보이는
특성이 있다. 어 실적이 후반부로
갈수록 가파르게 오르기 때문이고요.
수요 모멘텀이 둔화되는 분면부터는 저
PR주로 변하게 된다라고 하는데 최근
주가 급락은 수요 둔화를 반영하는
것으로 판단을 하고 연말 이후 실적
모멘텀도 꺾일 전망이고 내년 이후
밸루에이션도 더 이상 싸지 않는다.
싸지 않다는 판단입니다. 한편 ADR
발행은 중립적으로 보고 있는데요.
해외 현지 거래 편의성은 제공을
하지만 원주 밸류에이션이 달라지지는
않을 것이다. ADR도 보수적으로
보시고 내년 실적에 대한 것도
보수적으로 보고 지금 빅테크들의 AI
케펙스 내년 투자에 대해도 보수적인
관점으로 보고 있는 거 같습니다.
사실상 완전 숏 리포트 느낌으로
제시를 한 거 같고요.
아래 실적 추정치로 가서 보면 최근에
보여 드렸던 전자와 하이닉스의
다른 연구원님들 추정치랑은 매우
상반되는 모습인데요.
내년 매출액을
어 굉장히 낮게 보고 있는 거
같아요. 올해 추정치가
343조인데 내년에 266조입니다.
매출 추정치도 확 내려갈 곳으로
추정을 하고 있고요. 올해 예상 영업
이익을 270조로 보고 있는데 내년에
185조기
때문에 이익이 확 꺾여서 내려갈 거
같다라는 전망이고 영업 이익률도
올해가 80% 전망인데 내년 되면
69%로
쭉 떨어질 것으로 추정을 했습니다.
랜드 쪽은 사실
랜드가 지금 더 쇼티인데 랜드
쪽조차도 내년에 마진이 한 20%
포인트 내려갈 것으로 추정을 하고
있어서 굉장히 보수적인 스탠스로
접근을 하고 있는 거 같습니다.
>> 네. [목을 가다듬음]
참 보면 우리나라에서이 반도체
애널리스트 한다는게음
시총이 크다 보니까 제일 중요하다
보니까 반도체 애널리스트들이 많고
제일 비싸고 제일 뭐 모든 하우스가
반도체 애널리스트 없으면 안 될
정도로 그렇긴 한데 좀 약간 또
마음이 약간 좀 짠하네요.이
반도체 맞추기가 힘들거든. 저는이
추정치불을 보면서 뭐 분리시하게 보는
분들이나 배열리시하게 보는 분들이나
사실
인연 추정치 이게 맞은 적이 사실
없거든요. 예. 맞은 적이 없기
때문에 예. 다 본인들이 이거 추정할
때마다 나름대로 추정을 하는데 저는
추정치가 하여튼 맞은 적이 별로 없어
가지고
저을 때마다 좀 항상 이래 고민이
되겠다. 그런 약간 애잔한 마음이
약간 듭니다. 근데 뭐 애잔할 필요가
없는게이
이런 주식을 매매하는 우리 펀드
매니저들도 엄청 스트레스잖아요.
그죠?이
이 추정치가 어 예측이 안 되는 그런
섹터를 가지고 매매를 해야 답다
보니까 그래서 어려운 건데 그 어렵기
때문에요
반도체에
대한 매매만 잘해도 남들이 다 어렵고
월른법회 촬리먼도 투자를 안 하는
섹터기 때문에
>> 우리가 잘하면 어 우리가이 어려운 걸
잘하면
김현아 선수 아사마우의 트리플 악세
다른 선수는 못 해도 우리는 하면
세계 최정상에 수익을 낼 수가 있기
때문에
잘 봐야 되는데음
예 배이시한
어 리포터도 하나 들고 왔고 어제는
KB 우리 김동훈 판사형님 아주
>> 뭐 내동 매매하지 마라
리포트 내동 매매하지 말아요.
>> 흔들리지 마라.
>> 예. 흔들리지 마라. 부안동하지
마라.
>> 예.
>> 어.
>> 이게 각각의이 다른 리포트를
살펴봤습니다.
자. 어,
리포트는 다 읽어 봤고요. 오늘 밤
이제 미국 시장 어떻게 됐는지 한번
살펴보겠습니다.
[목을 가다듬음]
어떻게 돼요?
저는 오늘 밤 상승할 거 같습니다.
>> 상승.
>> 네.
>> 어제는
>> 하락을
>> 하락.
>> 네.
>> SMP배 어제 나스닥 하락
SMP
우리 최부 사장님은 필범 상승
>> 나도 상승한다 얘기해. 전문
상성하다고 예. [웃음]
>> 이번에도 어떻게 한 15% 정도
빠지니까 반등이 나오네요. 예. 그
>> 신기하게도
>> 딱 기술적으로도 반등 자리였기 때문에
>> 예
>> 뭐 뭐
>> 트럼프 대통령하고 뭐이란 난리쳐도
저는 반등 들어오는 자리였기 때문에
예상했는데 오늘 어떻게 된다고요?
>> 저는 상승할 것 같습니다.
>> 어디? SP 500인가?
>> 어 네
>> 뭐죠? 나스닥인가 뭐예?
>> 제가 SMP 500
>> SP 500
>> 알아? 상승 상승
>> 상승 장면
>> 장프로 상승네
>> 나스닥 상승
>> 어 어제는 하락이었는데 오늘 상승은
왜 어떤 이유가
>> 아 어제
이란이랑 미국 이슈가 있어서 리랑
유가 쪽에 상승이 있었는데도 좀
[콧방귀]
어제 전일자로 미국 장이 좀 전주의
나스닥 쪽에서 상승하는 모습 보여줘서
정국 이슈에 좀 더 민감하지 않나
싶어서 비번 정
>> 오케
나스다 모드 상승
일반 어떻게 됩니까? 저도 상승이라고
생각하는데
>> 네
>> 어제 메타 뉴스가 굉장히 컸다고
생각합니다. 어 결국 그 DNK
이민이 연구원님도 어 가정 자체가
어 인프라 투자 속도 조절 가능성
높아죠뭐 이렇게 돼 있으면서이 가정이
어떻게 되느냐에 따라서 그 AI
인프라의 핵심에 있는 어 반도체 쪽이
상당히 영향을 받을 수 있다고
생각하거든요. 그런 면에서 어제
메타의 그 뉴스는이 인프라 쪽에 그
그간의 우려를 좀 씻어 주지 않았나
그런 생각이 듭니다. 그리고
>> 어 엔비디아 또 브로드컴 관련돼서 어
기업들의 어떤 반도체 관련 뉴스도 좀
좀 긍정적으로 보이고요. 그래서 어
저는 이제 그
하이퍼스케일러들이 실적 발표할 때 할
때까지 좀 공백기라고 생각했는데 어
메타가 그 공백기를 좀 끊어 준 거
같아요. 그래서
>> 상상할 것 같습니다.
>> 네.
>> 근데 한편으로 좀 전에 그런 생각이
들더라고.
>> 네.
>> 아니 메타가
그동안에 메타랑 마이크로소프트랑이
체피pt 나온 이후로
>> 예. 엄청나게 AI 쪽에 뭘 하겠다고
막 질러됐잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 그런데
어떻게 보면 방향을 약간 튼 건가?
클라우드를 하겠다고.
>> 아, 메타가요?
>> 예.
>> 어, 메타가
>> 그걸 잘 모르겠더라고.
>> 아, 메타가 자체 인프라를 통해서
수익성 개선, 생산성 개선의 힘을
썼다면
>> 그거 플러스
애드업에서 클라우드 서비스까지
진출하지 않았나? 음진출을 하고 있
>> 그 GPU를 제일 많이 샀던 회사가
23, 24년도에 메타랑
마이크로프트였습니다.
>> 메타는 GPU를 사 가지고 뭘 했던
거예요?
>> 어, 내부 프로세스. 그러니까 메타가
주로 하는 것이
>> 디지털 마케팅이잖아요. 어, 결국
아, 네. 페이스북이나 인스타그램 아
타겟 마케팅 이쪽에 이제 생생성
개선이나 효율성 개선 그리고 내부적인
어떤 어 인력 비용 개선 어 이런
거를 통해서 초기에 한 1, 2년
정도는 상당히 급격하게 어 그
생산성이나 그런 수익성이 개선되면서
영업 이익률이 좀 가파르게 높아지는
그런 현상이 나타났었습니다. 근데 어
지금 상황은 그게 이제 조금 둔화되고
하다 보니까 어 그리고 또 생각했던
그 전략 자체 그러니깐 어 비싼
인력을 데려다 데려다 놓고 신사업을
추진을 하려고 했는데 그게 좀 잘 안
되다 보니까 어 이번에 그 데이터
센터의
일부를 갖다가 어 클라우드 사업으로
전환하는 어 그런 어 계획을 세우고
그게 이제 남는 인프라가 아니라 어
거기에 추가해서 추가되는 데이터
센터에서 클라우드 사업을 더
추진하겠다 이렇게 좀 적극적인 행보를
보이고 있지 않나라고 생각합니다.
>> 문상뭐 좀 추가 코멘트 할 거
있나요?
어 이제 컴퓨터 외부 판매하는 것들은
이제 사실 되고 있는 거 같고 어
내부적으로 소유 초율성은 지속적으로
지금 추구를 하고 있는 거 같고 슈퍼
인텔레지던스 모델을 지금 준비
중이어서 출시하면은 어 최선단
모델보다는 조금 성능이 낮지만은 견줄
수 있는 모델들이 지금 나올
예정입니다.
>> 슈퍼 인텔리전스 모델이라는 게
>> 예
>> 차대 이제 AI 모델을 지금
개발했거든요. 그래요. 테스팅 단계고
한 몇 달면 나올 것 같습니다.
>> 그게 뭐 재미나이나 철피트 같은
거죠.
>> 예. 그럼 외부 모델로 지금 준비를
하고 있습니다.
>> 그래서 그런 쪽으로 이제 질러대다가
이거 아닌가
그러면서 아예 클라우드나 하자.이
나는 요런 개념인 건지 갑자기 좀
헷갈리더라고.
>> 스펙 X가 클라우드 사업의 그
가능성을 보여 줬기 때문에 메타도
따라하는 거 같습니다.
>> 스페이스 X가
>> 예. 아, 스페이스엑도 클라우드예요.
>> 예. XI의 그 유 클라우드를 다 몇
번에 계약을 했고 그것만으로도 이제
BB 들어줄 수 있는 수준이 되는 거
같습니다.
>> 그래서 그게 좀 헷갈린다는 거죠.
스페이스 X도 X AI하고 그동안에
구글도 하고 재미나이 같은 거
>> 엔스로픽 달라들었고 그래서이 AI
인프라 사이클이라고 우리는 봤잖아요.
>> 네.
그러면서 그쪽에 막 질러됐었는데
지금 메타가 발표한 거는 그쪽을 더
질러된다는게 아니라
그 남아 도니까이 남아 도는 컴퓨팅
파워를 어 클라우드로 좀 하자. 아,
그러니까 투추랙으로 가는 거 같아요.
AI 모은 요쪽대로 질러되고. 예.
>> 근데 그쪽 질러되는게 최근에 나왔던
노이저가 막 질러됐는데
어 제가 저번에도 얘기했지만 막 질러
놨는데 그 GPU에 대한 활용이
쪽 질러놨는데 뭐
활용이 막 풀케파로 막 돌아가야
되는데 뭐 풀캐파로 돌아가지 않으니까
남는 컴퓨팅 파워를
>> 이쪽으로 돌리는 거 아닌가? 그리고
돌려는 놨는데 그러면 우리가 옛날
구형 GPU를 쓴 거를요 뭐 돌렸다
그러는데
그렇다 하더라도
이쪽에 계속 질러야 되는데 질러되고
이쪽에 남는 거는 클라우드로 돌리고
이거는 많이 되는데
>> 왜 캐나다에가 생뚱맞게
>> 데이터 센터 주차를 발표했냐
>> 그래서 우리 처부장 말할 때로 이쪽은
계속 질러내고 클라우드도 좋으니까
클라우드도 하자예 뭐요 개념은 아닌
거 같은데 최근에 메타의 형보는
어떻게 생각해요?
아, 근데 세 가지 다 하고 있는 거
같아요. 내부 효율화를 지금 급진적
시키려고 투자하는 [목을 가다듬음]
것도 있고
신규 모델 준비해서 이제 모델
판매하는 용도로도 있고 그리고
클라우만을 위해서 하는 용도 있고
왜냐면 지금 클라우이 지금
쇼티지예요. 계속적으로 엔트로픽이나
이런데 장애가 계속 생기거든요.
그래서 본인들은 원하는 물량은 지금
두 배 정도 원하는데 50%밖이 안
되고 있다라고 계속 공격전하게
이야기를 하고 있기도 하고 실제 사용
상에서도 계속 래깅이 걸리고 있는
상황입니다. 선단 모델들 같은
경우에. 그래서 그 삼박자가 다
메타가 추가하는 경향인 거 같고
그리고 GPU 활용률을 말씀을
하셨는데 GPU를
>> 그 못 돌려서 못 돌리는게 아니고
병목이 생겨서 그래요. GPU가
병료를 마무리 처리를 해 줘도
>> 메모리랑 CPU랑 네트워킹이 받아주지
못해서 GPU GP는 나름대로 지금
풀가동이에요. 그렇지만
>> 그니까 우리가 뇌를 100% 못 쓰고
있잖아요. 10%밖 못 쓴다고
하잖아요. 그거는 마큰 맥락이에요.
출력할 수 있는 루트가 없는 거예요.
그래서 풀가동하고 있지만은
허용 가능한 상황 그 해파 안에서
풀가동인 거고 이거를 그 지금
집필 가동률이 하는 활용률이
활용률이라고 하게 더 맞는 표현이죠.
30% 정도 된다고 하고 있거든요.
요걸 늘리기 위해서는 메모리 CPU
네트워킹이
두 배세배가 늘어나야 GPU가 이제
돌아가지 않는 부분들을 충족시켜 줄
수 있는 거예요. 그래서 현실적으로
지금 GPU는 풀가동으로 하고 있는
거예요.
>> 본인의 영향이 닿는 대까지. 그래서
오히려 이제 앞으로는 계속적으로
매몰이나 네트워킹 이런 쪽으로 지금
포커스가 맞춰 준 이유 자체도
GPU가
[목을 가다듬음] 비싸니까는 이걸
늘리는 것보다는 늘린 것도 있겠지만은
이쪽을 늘 반대편을 늘리는게 조금 더
싸게 먹히니까는 그 병체적으로 가고
있습니다. 지필드 지필드로 최대한
받아와서 하는 데까지 해보고 이걸
활용 올리기 위해서
밸류 체인도 같이 올려서 그럼
투트랙으로 가면은 최대한의 퍼포먼스를
뽑아낼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 알겠습니다.
병문 얘기하니까 조금 이해가 되긴
합니다.
자 우리 시장 어떻게 시작했어요?
네. 시작했고요. 어 플러스
3.31%로 상승해서 출발했고요.
현재 3.47%로
소폭 상승폭 조금 더 확대하고
있습니다.
>> 네. 어제 하도 많이 빠져 놓으니까
3.5% 올랐는데도 아직
7,496이네요.
>> 코스닥은 어떻게 되고?
>> 네. 코스닥 + 1.02%로 상승해서
출발했고요. 현재 플.
소폭 하락하고 있습니다.
>> 네. 스스닥은 낙폭에 비해서이 반등이
그렇게 세게 들어오지는 못하고 있다.
그죠?
>> 자, 종목별 삼성전자 하이닉스 어떻게
되고 있습니까?
>> 네, 삼성전자 4%대 상승하고
있고요. 하이닉스가 7.7% 37%
어 상승을 하고 있습니다.
>> 그리고 그 외의 종목들은 대체적으로
지금 보합세나 아니면 권주들은 뭐
1%대 상승 보이고 있고요.요
>> 정도 될 거 같습니다.
그러니까 어제 신문 읽다 보니까이
하이닉스 쪽의 청약도 좋고 그리고
그러니깐 그 미국 시장에는 투자할 수
있는데 한국 시장에는 투자를 못하는
글로벌 펀드들
>> 입장에서는 일단 무조건 들어오긴
하겠더라고 그죠?
>> 네.
그 수요가 분명히 있을 것 같아서
그래서 오늘하고 내일 내일 하이닉스가
ADR이 상정이 됐다고 했을 때
>> 어 흐름이 나쁘지 않겠더라고요.
가격도 이제 충분히 매력적인 가격이
이렇게 빠져 줬으니까
>> 그 부분이 일단 내일까지는
하이닉스의 강세가 좀 이어질 수
있겠다. 그리고 흑국로 봤을 때 그걸
미리 풀리 좀 선반영을 하면
>> 축국을 봤을 때 강세 현상의
어
뭐 크게 더 추가적인 부분은
마이크론하고
하이닉스랑 삼성전자 전체적으로 이제
메모리가 얼마나 또 반등을 이어가는가
방법 그럼 메타의 노이즈가 계속
잔상이 남아 있기 때문에
>> 예이
>> 부분은 어떻게 극복하는 거 아니고
>> 단기적으로는 는이 ADR 상장 효과가
분명히 좀 있는 거 같아요.
자, 그렇고요.
국내 시장 어떻게 될 것 같습니까?
왕박사
안 보내.
>> 아, 이제는 왕박사가 음봉하면 좀
무섭긴 해요.
사실 종목별로 보면 진짜 처참한
거죠. 그렇죠. 예. 처참한데
>> 주식 시장이라는게 또 냉혹하다 보니까
>> 반대 매매가 또 반대 매매를 부르고
그런 모습들이
또 부착되고 오늘 오전에도 아마 그
모습이 약간 좀 이어질 것 같긴네.
>> 저 코스피는 어떻게 됩니까?
어제는 양봉 얘기했.
>> 네. 양봉이는데 큰 문봉이 났었고요.
어제
볼린저단이 깨지니까더라고요.
그래서 일봉상자 깼다가 오늘 다시
위로
올라온 상황인데 뭐 이번에 1한
전쟁급으로
받았었다라고 볼 수 있어서
오늘 반대 매매가 이제 시간대별로 또
나오긴 하겠지만
오늘은 기술적 반등으로라도 양봉
가능성이 좀 더 높지 않을까
싶습니다.
오늘은
>> 양봉이
>> 양봉. 어제도 양봉이었는데 오늘은
진짜 양봉.
>> 오늘은 찐 양봉입니다.
>> 찐 양봉.
알겠습니다.
자 우리 본배팅 님이
정말 또 좋은 명언을 올려줬어요.
주셨는데 네만델라의 명어. I
never lose. I either
win or love.
세부사장님 예
>> 어
>> 맨설 만델라의 명언
>> 예 저는
어 [웃음]
뭐 뭐라고 하시면 잘 못 들었습니다.
아예 이들러
>> 아 이들
>> 나는 절대 읽지 않아 실패하지 않아
>> 왜냐면 이기거나 피우거나
>> 음
>> 그래서 뭔가 도전을 했는데
>> 제대로 되면 우인이고 실패했어
실패하면 그 실패에서 배웠다는 거지.
음.
그러니까요. 굉장히 위대한 명언이 I
never lose.
>> 예.
>> 그거 어떻게 보면
>> 외워야 되겠
>> 그 실패할까 봐 시도 못하는 그런
경우가 많잖아요. 예.
>> 그니까 사실 어제
>> 그걸 극복해야 되는 거죠. 그
30대 분들 같은데이 기자 두 분하고
점심을 먹었는데
>> 예.
>> 예. 그러면서 뭐 이런저런 저 주식
얘기 많이 했지. 정권부
기자들이니까.
>> 이런저런 얘기 많이 하다가 어
인생을 어떻게 살아야 되는지 뭐 그런
얘기도 하다가 맨 마지막에 그런
얘기를 했어요.
>> 예. 제가 얘기하잖아요. 깔까 말까
할 때는 가. 그죠? 갈까 말까는
가라고.
안 가서 나중에 좀 후회하고
미안하고이 뭐 경조사 같은 거 예를
들어가. 경조사 갈까 말까 하 쟤
별로 나랑 안 친했는데 뭐
>> 근데 나중에 만나잖아요. 안 가면
>> 만나면 미안해요. 그렇죠.
>> 근데 아 갈까 말까 하는데 가주잖아.
어 뭐 평생 만날 때마다 걔한테
저번에 어 와줘서 고마워 그 소리
듣는다고.
>> 그러면 가지는 못하더라도 10만
원이라도 보내면 돼. 그 10만 원
보낸 걸로 평생 볼 때 미안한 거
없어지는데 그거 안 보내잖아요.
>> 그면 다음에 마주치면 어 무습하고
미안해
>> 뭐 그런 얘기 하면서 어 결국은 이제
액션 어제 여러 가지 어떤 얘기를 해
줬는데 그걸 지키고 실행하는 거는
본인들 몫시라는 거죠.
>> 그렇죠. 음.
>> 본인도 몫인데
>> 지나고 보니까 결국 성공한 사람들은
>> 성공한 사람이 실패 없이 성공한게
아니라
>> 음
>> 계속 도전하다가 우리도 뭐 그렇잖아.
뭐 최분성도 뭐 우리도
>> 그렇습니다.
>> 실하다가 실패하고 하다가 실패하고
하다가 한 번 딱 성공하면 되는
거예.
>> 그죠? 한번 성공하면
>> 그래서 성공한 분들이 마치 그동안에
실패 없이 성공한 거 같은데 제가
주식 투자도 그랬다 했잖아요. 저희
주변에 500억 이상 보신 분들의
공통점이 나 반지아
>> 반지아에서 봤었고
>> 마포 대교 한 두 번 근데 절대 제가
뛰어내리지 말자
>> 뛰어내릴까 말까 절대 뛰어내리면 안
돼요 그거
>> 왜냐면 끝까지 예 끝까지 살아남아서
계속 도전하고 실패하고 도전하고
실패하다가
>> 한번 성공하면 되는 거
>> 한번 성공하면 돼
>> 아니 뭐 실패해 봐야 어차피 뭐
이병적 설 회장님 그저께 그 액자
샘터에다가
기정하셨다는 공수의 공수 어차피
빈손유로와
뭐 실패해 와야 뭐 그렇잖아 어차피
빈손유으로 와서 그동안에
>> 벌었던 거 잃는 거 그게 안 돼요.
그래서 계속 성공한 사람들의 특징은
계속 도전한 사람이구나.
아이고 이꿈님이 아 전문님 옛날 사람
말이 너무 [웃음]
그래서네 절대 뛰어내리면 안 되고
끝까지 하여튼
>> 예
>> 끝까지 해 보는데
>> 도전하지 않고 알리바바의 마인이
얘기했던 것처럼 어 안 하는 사람은
게으른 사람은
학자 교수들보다 더 많은 생각을
한다는 거죠. 무슨 생각?
>> 안 할 생각. 왜 이걸 하면 안
되는지에 대한 생각을 많이
>> 그러면서 정말 대단하십니다.
>> 뭐가요? 이것저것 시도 되게 많이
하시잖아요.
>> 그러니까 아 제가 보니까
아버지께서 [웃음] 제발 세이기 일
벌리는 거 좀 말리하라고 하셨던게
2007년에 말씀하셨는데
>> 그 20년 동안 그 일벌리던 거
말리라 하신게 그 일식집 투자했던
거죠.
>> 쫄딱망했잖아.
강북 아파트 한채 날렸잖아요.
[웃음]
>> 아무튼 어 주식 시장이 왔다 갔다
하는게 좀 마음 이렇게 속상하신
분들도 많으시는데
>> 계속 도면 하시면 되고 근데 도전도
보면 연습장에서 보면 엉터리로
연습하는 사람들
>> 맞습니다.
>> 예 엉터리 많습니다.
저 저희가 그나마 하나 자신있게
말씀드릴 수 있는 거는이 체슬리 모닝
브리프
이걸 보시면서 꾸준히 하시면 어
반드시 선수가 되실 수가 있을
주식으로 성공하실 수 있다라는 거
>> 아티
>> 예 맞습니다. 그 제가 재밌는 얘기
하나 해 드리면은 제가 골프를 안
하잖아요. 원래 골프를 안 한게
아니라 좀 처음에 좀 열심히 했는데
>> 그 연습장 프로님이 그러시더라고요.
>> 야 그렇게 공 몇 트럭을 쳐 봐라.
실력이 드나? 어 그런 [웃음]
식으로 그렇지 엉터리로 그러니까요.
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 근데 이제 어 고치려고 고치려고 해도
되게 안 고쳐지더라고요. 저는 그
>> 나름 또 보집도 있고 해 가지고
그래서 아예 안 하기로 했습니다.
[웃음]
>> 그리고
>> 본인이 잘하는 걸 해야 돼.
>> 예. 본인이 잘할 수 있는 거.
>> 음. 운동도 뭐 본인이 잘할 수
있는게 있거든.
자, 그래서 양봉
>> 음봉
>> 그리고 샤오미 코멘트만 듣고 끝내도록
할
>> 쇼미는
시험이 핵심 포인트는 그냥 결국은
한편 GP 마진율 총이잖아요. GP
마진 얼마 정도 나올 수 있는지 그
핵신 포인트이고요.
>> 지난번 그 사이클 때는 또 거의 바다
통과하고 주가는 반등 시작했어요.
그래서 저는 시간이 많아요. 금방금번
주가 올라가는 거 아니고 대초는 뭐
한 번기 두 번기 정도가 체크하고
들어가도 되는데 지금 상 시 시장
시장 상황 보면은 2, 3분기는 GP
마진을 좀 받아 나올 수 가능성이
있다고 보고 있어요. 내년부터는 다시
올라갈 수 가능성이 있어요. 8%에서
9%
>> 이날 지난도 크나 그시기 그때는 거의
비슷한 수준이고요.
어
다만 그대는 전기차 없어요. 지금
전기차 있어요. 그게 맞네. 맞아요.
맞아요. 전기차 있고요.
>> 전기차는 형군 승장 모멘텀도 받을 수
있는 사업이니까 군차고요.
장기적으로 관정하면은 되게 좋고요.
단기적으로는 시험이 사는 사람이 그냥
매물이 안쪽에 사는 음이
>> 그래서 안축해 부는 사람이 시험에
사면 되고요.
>> 아
>> 매물이 계속 갈 수 있다고 생각하면
사면 안 되겠고
>> 네. 그 페어로 사
>> 지금부터 1년 두고 보면 사도 될 거
같은데. [웃음]
>> 네. 장기적으로 [목을 가다듬음]
하면은 괜찮고요. 네. 다만이 종간
박스권에서 좀 잘 버텨야 합니다.
>> 자, 본나베팀 님은 다음에 어 좋은
책 나오면 하나 보내 드릴테니까
아닙니다. 오늘 전화 주세요. 오늘
또 책이 뭔가 좋은 책 하나 와
있었는데. 가끔가끔 한 마디씩
던지셨는데 어 되게 좋은 거
같습니다.
>> 예
최근에 나온 책 한 건 보내 드리도록
하네 채슬님 모니브리프 오늘 7월
9일 목요일 주는 여기까지
하겠습니다. 잠깐만 오늘 목요일
맞죠? 오늘이 만긴 날이네.
>> 어
>> 외국인들 그러니까 풋 옵션 어제
400몇억 때리더니 결국 멈다고.
자, 오늘 만기 변동성 잘
대응하시고요.
저희 채슬리와 함께 행복하고 슬기로운
투자하시기 바라겠습니다. 고맙습니다.
감사합니다.